Thanks for watching!
do do
Bye!
State board will reconvene and we'll take up item one, which is the assessment item.
And I have several different items here, so we'll have multiple presenters for various parts of this item.
So Michelle Center will start.
Good morning.
Michelle Senner, Director of the Assessment Division here at the Department.
What I provided to you was both an information item as well as an action item.
And as has become my approach, I, of course, have a team to help me with my items.
So, this morning, Karek Ashley will present to you on the CASP results.
And then myself, as well as Kenji Hakuta, will be presenting to you on part of the action, which is the Spanish assessment.
And then I will also present to you on the other action part of this item, which is the California alternate assessment.
There are many other topics that are for your information in this item, but I will only be presenting on those three topics you just heard me outline.
So if you have questions afterwards on anything else in the item, I'm open to that.
But let's start with with Carrick.
Good morning, Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent.
So hopefully you've all received a handout of the slides from this morning.
We're going to go over the CASP results.
We did provide a handout since I know the screen is a little low down for some to see.
There we go.
So we did talk a little bit about this yesterday.
Since we did the press release at the end of August, we haven't had a board meeting since then to actually talk about it as a group, so this is our opportunity.
The 3.2 million kids again took the test, a second year of successful implementation.
I think you heard from the superintendent's report yesterday that a very small number of students opted out of the test, so the support for Common Core
across the state is still strong.
The state of the state when it comes to Smarter Balance is strong and the results also indicate very good progress across the board.
Every grade level, every student subgroup, race and ethnicity, folks across the board in English language arts and math, gains were made by all.
So an overview here shows where we were in the orange from the 2015 results.
The green tells you the additional growth that was made.
On the left side, the bars for English language arts.
On the right is math, and you can see an increase of five percentage points in English language arts and four in mathematics.
So we should probably stop right now and say that this was part of the discussion yesterday, that this is only one lens of the way that we look at this data, and in some ways it doesn't tell the whole picture.
It only tells the picture of those who met or went above the standard, which is what these charts recognize.
One of the reasons for that is that
We are required by the federal government to report the data in this way of the four levels and how many are at or above what is considered standard, in the past what they called proficient.
All states report the data this way, and this is what the news media tends to pick up on.
particular metric.
So one of the things that we again we talked about yesterday was trying to change the conversation a little to move beyond just this metric of those bubble kids if you will that went over level three and or level three and or four.
to talk about how did all kids across the state do, kids in level one, kids in level two.
If nothing else, at a very minimum, we should be looking at kids that cross lines, thresholds in all four levels, but even better, looking at each and every student and seeing how they did.
Our problem is our resources.
Our staff is busy doing everything that is required by the federal government to try to meet our responsibilities by the end of August to get this data up and available to the public before the start of the school year.
So there is very little time to do any real data analysis beyond this.
So I guess part of my presentation this morning is sort of a call, if you will, because we need to partner with someone out there, some good-hearted university, because we don't have money to give them.
that might be willing to take a look at this data and to be able to look at perhaps scale scores.
I know Linda Darling-Hammond in the Learning Policy Institute did that a little bit and was emailing back and forth with her last week.
And her quick analysis, she wouldn't call it thorough, but her quick analysis showed that kids in different grade levels were closing gaps.
And that's the sort of thing we need to look at.
But we really do need a partner to do that because, quite frankly, aside from Smarter Balanced, our assessment division is working on six different assessments and different stages of development at this time.
So there just isn't the time and the resources for us to look really in depth at an analysis of the data.
But what we do have shows very good results.
Here it is by grade level.
You can see for English Language Arts, you can see, again, every grade level in English Language Arts made some growth, at least looking at this lens of the data.
I want to call out grade six, especially.
They made a six point gain in, again, kids that were at or above standards.
I can tell you, well, let's look at math.
Math also, though math overall doesn't do as well as English Language Arts,
Overall, again, growth across all of the grade levels.
Grade 3, in this instance, made, again, six points of growth for grade 3.
I can tell you, just to put it in context, that I am very pleased with these results, and we are going to look at some other results here in a minute.
I will say, if you were to look at other Smarter Balanced States, not all of them have released their data yet.
Probably about almost half of the Smarter Balanced States have released their data.
Smarter Balanced States are seeing gains across the board in other states, though I will say that not as high a gain as we are finding here in California.
So if you kind of put this in context with our accountability system that we're trying to look at status and change, our status, not as high as some of our neighboring states, smarter balanced states like Oregon and Washington, started higher than us.
But if you were to look at the change,
Our change is higher than those states.
So good news in that respect.
I would not necessarily expect five and six point gains every year.
I do think it's reasonable to expect gains each year, and that certainly is our goal.
gains probably closer in the area of one to two to three percentage points, which is what we saw in states like Oregon and Washington, are probably more reasonable expectations than some of these that really, really jumped like five and six points.
So looking at gender is one example here in English language arts and math.
Some good gains, especially by female students in English language arts.
in looking at some of the race and ethnicity groups.
You can see especially Hispanic students growing by five percentage points, with a reminder that that Hispanic subgroup contains a lot of English learners within it.
So even with all of those English learners within that subgroup, making a five-point gain in English language arts is actually remarkable.
And then some of our, again, some of the other student groups, especially, I think we ought to be pleased with the growth of economically disadvantaged students here by making a four-point gain across the board, which, again, also includes students with disabilities and English learners within that economically disadvantaged subgroup.
So as we mentioned yesterday,
We do need to look at the data for more analysis, especially when it comes to an English learner subgroup.
I think we need to change our focus or the way that we look at English learner data differently than some other groups.
There's a reason why, even with the new federal law, there is a specific metric to show and to look at kids learning English along the way.
That is the only subgroup that has that kind of special accountability measure for them.
I think we need to put our emphasis more than we have in the past on how our kids are doing in learning English.
Learning English is going to be the key for them to then perform in Smarter Balance.
As we mentioned yesterday, the English learners subgroup is a changing subgroup.
So if you had 100 students, as Member Rucker said yesterday, if you had 100 students, say, in the African American subgroup, and let's say 100 of them scored in levels three and four,
The next year, you're starting with those same 100 students minus who are the kids transferred out, but you're starting with those 100 kids.
So to move five percentage points, you need now 105 kids in that group.
In the English subgroup, if you were to have 100 kids in that English learner subgroup, those 100 kids that scored in levels 3 and 4 really ought to be reclassified.
When they take the test the next year, they won't be in that subgroup.
You're basically starting
Theoretically, it's not true.
Theoretically, at zero, so to gain five points, they'd have to have 105 kids in that subgroup to make a 5% point gain.
So we just need to be careful that in comparing these gains, we have to look at English learners a little different than we do the other subgroups.
So, we do want to look at closing the achievement gaps.
This is not the best metric to do that.
This is one metric, one way of looking at the data, but this is not the best metric to see if we're closing gaps.
So, again, a little call for help out there that we might be able to partner with someone to give us a little bit of more background on that.
So, before we move on, back to Michelle Senter, any questions about overall data?
First of all, I always look forward to this report every fall and to hear with great interest what the data is going to tell us, not only about the implementation of Smarter Balanced and, again, giving clear evidence to the efficiencies and the good work of the Department.
I want to really make sure I begin by complimenting
Not only the good work to do the implementation in the field, but the work that the clear partnership with Smarter Balanced and ETS is showing in getting this implemented and doing that, but also the time that it takes to put this report together in a consumable and understandable way.
But this is where my question is.
Our charge as a state education agency is to address the achievement gap and to create a plan for not only intervention, oversight, and monitoring, but for collaborating now with our school districts to help them understand how to address the achievement gap.
What this report points out, and I appreciate your candor in talking about the capacity of the department, if we are unable to do the kind of data analysis that helps us figure out if the gaps are closing or where the gaps are changing, then what we are doing is more faith-based education reform than data-driven education reform.
And so in saying that, I think it is important for us to figure out not just how to collaborate with a university or some think tank or the experts that are clearly in the field.
Some of them are clearly in this room and some of them we even contract with.
but we might need to think about what it is we are asking of the people we currently contract with and is our contract, I'm sorry, reformed English teacher, are the contracts we're writing actually taking advantage of the expertise that our contractors clearly have to do a data analysis at a level of granularity that will give us this information beyond just simply collating the data and reporting it back.
So I agree with you, we should have universities and other programs involved in this because they would probably be more neutral and probably have to be able to look at the data and do the analysis at arm's distance.
But we have an obligation
to be able to figure out how to report and explain to the school community that spent all that time with us yesterday, this is what they were asking for.
So, it's not sufficient for us to sit here and say, it's not that we don't know how to do it, we don't have the capacity.
It is not sufficient for us to sit here and say that.
So we had a member of the legislature here yesterday who was talking about her idea for the accountability system.
Maybe the conversation needs to be with the legislature to talk about how we build the state's capacity to do the work that you've just outlined.
So I'm very glad that we see this conversation today because here's the other dimension that's going to happen.
Having adopted this accountability rubric yesterday,
When at some point in time, your division is going to have to start giving us data about that rubric.
If you don't currently have the capacity to do the reporting beyond the six tests you're already monitoring, how are you going to develop the capacity
to prepare a report for the board about the information the rubric is telling us about the performance of schools in the state.
So I want to congratulate you first of all for the work you're doing, for the reporting that's going on.
I think you have a fantastic crew of folks with the expertise to do this work and I congratulate you on that.
But I also think we have very strong partnerships and the ability because of
uh the size of this state and the market that this the market share this state represents to actually throw some weight around in the in the assessment community to say we need you to do a different type of reporting and consider how to use the capacity of your organization to do that because as long as we fail to figure out how to do this the monitoring on the achievement gap
We will not be doing real data-driven reform and really making data-driven decisions that this board is charged to do.
So I'm hoping I said that in a way that wasn't a criticism of your staff and the department, but more a concern about the opportunities we're missing in the way we're currently contracting with our vendors.
Yes, thank you, Mr. President.
I couldn't agree with you any more, Pat, in terms of that observation.
And to let you know, besides looking for outside sources of help and research, we have been working for the last six months with the Latino caucus and the legislature, the African-American caucus, the API caucus, on creating an office of education equity or a team of education equity where we'd have our own internal staff with secure funding over
number of years that would really look, really focus in on the achievement gap and really focus in on the opportunity gap.
And you look at these results and, you know, are glad that we're seeing this kind of progress, but you talk to different folks in the field and they have different reasons for why
why the numbers went up, why they went up more in English language arts than in mathematics.
And they range from greater familiarity with the equipment, with the testing system, with the keyboard and other computer skills, with the material, with the new standards material and instruction, to the professional development.
The state, at our request, a collective request of the state board,
My office, the education community, we got a billion and a half in professional development money and it was very well invested right down to the school site sharing of best practices and countless webinars and seminars.
That was obviously a major contributor and we need to do more of that.
And I know the collaborative is looking at its role in that regard, but the enormity of reaching 10,000 schools and dealing with all the complexities
I think also we're past, and hopefully with the passage of Prop 55, past the chaos that existed during the recession years, where we had layoffs by the tens of thousands, we had bumping, we had school teams that had been built by administrators and principals that were sort of dismantled in the crisis.
So that stability, I think, has changed in bringing back
Things that attract students to stay in school from smaller class sizes, arts, music, drama, career tech, I think are making, are strides forward in tackling absenteeism and suspension and expulsion.
And those students are staying in school and learning and
not dropping out, and they're doing better, I think, on the test.
But how do you sort out among all those factors, I think they all contribute in some way.
So I'll look forward to, you know, Carrick and Michelle responding further.
I also wanted, though, to comment on Carrick's focus on English learners.
And again, we had some discussion yesterday, and we'll have continuing discussions.
It's one of our main missions is to
help English learners succeed?
And how much should we rely on reclassification as sort of a main indicator of whether English learners are successful?
What about two, three years down the road after reclass or after getting off the long-term English learner list?
So I think we have a challenge to work out here as a board, my department, your staff working together to figure out the strategies that will help us lift all English learners and close that gap.
Thank you, Superintendent.
And then let me respond to Member Rucker's comments.
So first, there are a couple of things at play here.
One is to try to figure out what are we going to do about the gap closure.
The other thing is the capacity to actually identify it well.
So the superintendent and I, during a press conference, went to San Leandro High School.
And while the state made a gain of five percentage points in English language arts and four in math, their high school students, African-Americans, made 10 percentage points.
And Hispanics made eight.
So we need to find out what's happening at some of the schools where they're having great success, which is not really an assessment data issue.
It's probably a curriculum, instruction, professional development issue, and then be able to share what some of those best practices are.
And maybe that's something, if this equity office were to come about, they could focus on.
Thank you for your comments.
I think what is key there, because you said it two or three times, is the current contract.
Smarter Balance and ETS have been great partners in this.
It is not Smarter Balance's responsibility to identify what California is going to do to identify those gaps, but they have been
providing great support to all of the states to look at their options, and as he mentioned yesterday, finding out what is it that the state wants to get out of the data that they have, which we'll have that conversation.
I can suppose, I can guess, that looking at gaps would be part of what we would want to see out of a system.
And if that's the case, then we need to focus on a metric that will allow us to do that more or better.
ETS has also done some, you know, they do small data analysis for us without extra cost, and they did that for us, for English learners, in a quick analysis.
So they, but again, we need to look at the contract and see what do we want to do moving forward, because you're right, it's not in the current contract.
But I do know that Michelle has some things that she
can tell you about the work with ETS, so I think I'll go ahead and turn it over to her.
So, just to follow up on what Carrick just mentioned, we also recognized, as Carrick mentioned in his presentation, that this isn't necessarily the best way to show the progress, particularly for the English learner subgroup.
So, we have been working with ETS.
looked at one approach and they were able to do a data run for us that focused on scale scores and it also focused on longitudinal, which this data that you see before here is not really a longitudinal data, right?
It's a snapshot last year, snapshot this year.
So, one of the approaches that we are investigating is what happens when you actually take that subgroup that was there last year and is still there this year, and look at their progress over that one-year period.
So, that's one approach we're looking at.
So, I didn't want to leave you with the impression that this is what we can do and we're done,
We are still investigating other options and additional ways to display the data.
I don't know that we're looking to replace the way that we currently display it, but we think that there are other ways to look at it that answer different questions than the questions that can be answered with the way it's displayed currently.
Board Member Holliday.
I do think this is an excellent report, and it shows that we've hit the ground running, and we're doing pretty well, and we don't know why there's a nice gain.
But in San Leandro, when there was a 10-point gain for African-Americans, I believe you said, what was the white student gain?
Was it also 10?
And I don't mean to put you on the spot, but as Felicia said yesterday, she and I can keep moving around the tables together, but she's never going to catch up with me if we just move one seat at a time.
So I really do think that this is the heart and soul of what this board is about currently and will be for any number of years, closing the achievement gap and really understanding that.
I didn't expect that data today.
I didn't expect that, but I certainly agree with Member Rucker.
This is the goal, this is our challenge, and so finding out what is the best method to calculate that, to help us understand that, and to single out those districts and schools that are achieving it and being able to learn from that.
We do need to move that way, so anything we all can do to help.
Can I answer the San Leandro question?
It's about 6%, I think, for Caucasian.
So there was a 6, 6.5%.
So there was a closure, and a lot of it they attribute to career tech education, hands-on, small schools within the big high school.
Yeah, one thing on this point I've never seen is, you know, there's got to be some kind of mathematical way of saying if you're going to close the achievement gap and assuming that the high end will make some gains as well, what increase is needed
in Smarter Balanced to do that?
I mean, okay, we know it's faster than X, because if we all do 5%, it's going, you know, you're not closing any gaps.
So what would it take
to make, you know, some significant progress?
What percent of gains?
I don't know how to figure this out, but I've never seen this.
So what should I be looking for?
What should I be shooting for, given that there's a relationship between the top and the bottom in gap analysis?
So I don't know what that is, and it would benefit from a simulation.
It's a simulation, in effect.
a projection simulation as to what it would take would help me in visualizing this.
I don't know, can you do that or is that, that seems to me possible?
What it sounds like you're describing is the work that needs to be done to develop the growth model.
Yeah, maybe, yes, but you, I think you can do this without a growth model.
You know,
I mean, I don't know, but it seems to me one could calculate it from now without having some fancy growth model that we're going to have.
But maybe that, it just strikes me that one could sit down and calculate this roughly without fitting it into a model.
You know, a model may be
A target.
I'm just trying to look at it visually to understand.
The model might say what you need to do each year or something.
I'm just trying to get a handle on it without... Maybe you have to have a growth model.
I don't know.
I think the model can get you different growth targets for those different subgroups, which I think gets to your wanting to close the gap.
So I'm happy there's many more people in the room that are smarter than I am on these topics, and we're happy to continue those conversations and present additional information.
I just don't know enough about growth models.
Yeah, go ahead.
I just, I feel like we really, as a state, should take a lead in this type of area.
And if we're talking about providing LEAs and schools on the LCFF rubric with information that they can, that is actionable, then this is the type of data that we should provide for them, especially for small schools or small districts that may not have the data capacity, but, and to be able to display this and it would be public and transparent and all of that.
I think it's more than just, it'd be great if we could figure it out at some point.
I think we really do need to be very proactive in taking leadership role in figuring how we do this.
Right.
Board Member Rucker.
As it relates to that kind of conversation, back when the Department was giving waivers to states to create these growth models, there were a lot of projects that came from different states that looked at different ways of doing it.
What President Kirst is asking about is this kind of trajectory growth model.
the state of Colorado, they didn't apply for this waiver, but they created kind of a hybrid growth model that's still available to other states as an open source application.
And what they do is they do actually use the data that is provided from the statewide assessment, and it identifies in ways how clusters, subgroups, and even individual students, what their performance needs to be to catch up if they're performing below proficiency,
to keep up if they are meeting or exceeding those standards, or even to move up, to catch up, keep up, and move up.
So the type of question that Dr. Kurtz is asking about is actually doable, but it goes back to the question that Carrick asked this board yesterday, what do you want the growth model to do?
If that is something we want the growth model to do, then that is the direction that we have to give you.
Do we want a regression model that would work to help us be able to figure out how to incorporate the grade 11 scores and connect them to the grade 8 scores?
Do we want a model that actually works at a level of granularity to help us understand the subgroup of English learners so that we can break out those different students that move out?
Different growth models work in different ways.
And maybe there's a hybrid that'll let us do all four of those functions.
I'm not sure if that's out there.
But there are growth models that will perform.
to do the things that we are asking about, but we have to decide not just what data we're trying to figure out, but what we're asking the growth model to do.
Now, and I want to say, and again, to give this compliment to Tony, Smarter Balanced knows how to do those things.
They have done that with a level of granularity when they did the field data, when they did the first field test reports, because they did impact data and they looked at
not only what the differences were among the states and the performance of subgroups on the field test, but they had impact data for individual states.
So some of their conversation about what they will do in looking at the scale scores and looking at where those cut points are is going to be informed by that baseline data.
Now, the differences between the other states and California, unlike other states, California tested the entire spread.
We tested grades three through eight and grade 11.
So we have a more diverse set of information in that state-level impact data that can inform some of the analysis that Smarter is going to do in looking at those scores and making some of those determinations about how to make those changes.
So again, as I said, their expertise is there.
It's something that we haven't asked them to do.
Our contract doesn't task them to do.
But it is information they have that they know how to use.
and they understand what they're looking at when they're reading it.
So it is doable, it is possible, but it goes back to the question Carrot gave us yesterday, what do we want to ask the growth model to do?
I move on to the next topic.
Okay, so can we proceed to the next item?
This is a multi-item.
So the first part of the action presented in this item today addresses the California Alternate Assessment, or the CAA, for English Language Arts.
It is on.
Can you hear me now?
So the CAA, I'll just speak louder.
Okay, the CAA is an alternate assessment administered in grades three through eight and 11 to students with the most significant cognitive disabilities.
That's less than 1% of the student population in California.
The CAAs, like all of California's assessments, are built on the assumption that students are receiving the appropriate grade level curriculum, instruction, accommodations, and access to technology they require.
The action before you today seeks approval of the superintendent's recommendations for the threshold scores for the CAA.
Threshold scores are the entry and exit points between the respective achievement levels.
They describe three levels of achievement for the CAA.
The approval of the threshold scores today, the action of this board, is necessary in order to provide results for the 2015-16 CAA.
While this may be the last board action prior to reporting the 2015-16 scores, each assessment year presents us with new opportunities for not only improving delivery of the assessments, but for our schools to improve their instructing of students with the most significant cognitive disabilities in their grade level standards.
The assessment division and the special education division will continue to work in coordinated and collaborative effort to support the field.
As you may know, development of standardized assessments for students with the most significant cognitive disabilities is no simple task.
Therefore, we will continue to support and listen to the field in how we can improve both the testing experience as well as assisting educators in identifying the most appropriate accessibility supports.
Additionally, it would be reasonable for us to take another look at these threshold scores after we have a few years of data.
Please also note an overview of the actions that were previously taken by this board and details of the standard setting process were provided in August information memorandum.
To arrive at these recommended thresholds, we convened a standard setting panel in August of 2016.
It included 68 California educators.
They had an average of 20 years of experience working with the student population.
These dedicated educators worked for four days utilizing the board's approved grade and content specific performance level descriptors.
As a reminder, these descriptors that were approved by the board earlier this year outline what students at each achievement level know and can do as measured by the CAA.
The standard setting panel's recommended thresholds are products of professional judgment through the use of the bookmark method, which is one of the most widely used standard setting procedures.
The superintendent's recommendations took into consideration fidelity to the panel's judgments, as well as looking for consistency of achievement across all the grade levels tested.
The superintendent's recommendations are located in tables one and two of the addendum and they have related 2015-16 student data in those tables.
While reviewing those recommended threshold scores, I would like to remind you of the board-approved policy descriptors for each of the three levels.
Level 3, documented in the table, are students demonstrating an understanding of the core subject matter in the content area and are actively working with adapted grade-level content that focuses on the essential knowledge and skills and may need occasional prompts and assistance to complete tasks.
Level 2 students demonstrate a foundational understanding of core subject matter in the content area when provided with frequent prompts and support and are actively working with adapted grade-level content that focuses on the essential knowledge and skills and may frequently need support to complete these tasks.
Level 1 students demonstrate a limited understanding of adapted grade-level content that focuses on much of the basic knowledge and skills even with extensive supports.
The 2015-16 data provided includes the percentage at or above for each of these achievement levels by each grade.
Also note that students who participated in the assessment but could not orient or did not respond to the test are included in the level 1 percentage.
You'll also note that when we actually do the reporting, we'll not be using the scales that you see in these tables.
Once we have the board action, we'll establish a reporting scale implementing the board approved threshold scores.
I don't know if you want to take questions on this or if I should present the next action also and take questions for all at the end.
What would the next item be?
Spanish no I we want to take questions on this and stop here so board member
So, Michelle, thank you for just laying this out really clearly.
I want to talk a bit about the standard setting, knowing that it's the first time we've done this.
And you talked about revisiting in a couple years.
Do you think that we should, I mean, your recommendation that then the committee that we should wait a few years to revisit it or take a look and see, do you believe that's the right?
And then the other question I had was, did we get any guidance at all from our
in NCSIC, or was this completely independent from what we did before?
This was independent.
The Department has conducted, along with its partners, ETS, many standard-setting workshops in the past, so this is not a new process for us at all.
We actually have in the audience Patty Barron from ETS, who
She probably can't count the number of standard setting workshops she has facilitated, so she is here with us if you have any questions on that.
So, it isn't that we have doubt in the threshold scores that we're putting before you today, but it is best practice, as we're developing a new assessment, to take a look at that after we have a few years of data.
the Common Core State Standards, while they have been around now for many years, this student population probably is not yet receiving that adapted content.
And so I think that is another reason why we should take a look at these again in a few years.
Also, it's a much smaller in size as well as far as that standard setting as well, so that could also lead to part of that.
OK, to split the items, I'd like to take public comment on this item, because I know there's some concerns about the difficulty of these items.
So one minute if there are any people that want to speak just on this item.
Oh, two minutes.
We have five people on the list.
Yeah, just on this item.
No, not the Spanish item.
So special ed.
You want to speak on special ed, I think.
You can speak later on Spanish.
I want to give people.
OK, come forward.
OK, I'll actually speak later on the 2016 results.
I wanted to speak on both.
OK, that's fine.
But let's stick with the Spanish item here.
I'm sorry, EL item.
There's a handout coming around.
I'll begin.
My name is Doug McRae.
I'm a retired test specialist from NRA.
The handout on the green paper coming around outlines information from the spring 2016 administration of CAA that's needed to evaluate the validity and the credibility of the threshold recommendations and I am addendum posted August 31.
The item addenda had no supporting data for the recommendations.
Without the data specified on this green handout, it's impossible for the public or the board to vet the recommended threshold scores.
Without that data, an action to delay approval until such data are available would be appropriate.
If the data are not consistent with the recommendations, the appropriate action, frankly, would be to delay approval of CAA threshold scores until spring 2017, when supporting data are available.
I attempted to get some clarification with the Department earlier this week by email.
and they were not able to share any of the data.
There was one piece of data that did come out in the presentation this morning, and that is that the students who were not able to orient to the test are included in things.
In the pilot test a year ago, or 2015, 37% of the students in this population were not able to orient to the test.
Only 63% oriented to the test.
NICSEC had roughly 15%.
If the test is not aimed at the full population,
You're not getting a very good range of coverage of the test.
Typically, test publishers like to have 95 to 98% coverage of the range.
63% does not come close.
We still do not know how many students did not orient to the test.
The other data on that handout are also needed.
The last one, comparison to the NICSEC, would be very useful to do inasmuch as the CAA effort is more or less modeled over the NICSEC thing.
So I would ask the Department to delay.
delay approval of this until the data is available to vet it, and possibly some of the Special Education Advisory Committee, for instance, have an opportunity to vet it.
Thank you.
This is on the alternative assessment only.
Special Ed.
Sorry, Mr. President.
Then general comments about the assessing item should wait?
Should wait.
Okay.
Sorry, I'll wait.
OK, so that's all the public comment.
Special Ed, ready.
Good morning, President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
My name is Gina Plate.
I chair the Advisory Commission on Special Ed, and I'm also an advisor at the California Charter Schools Association.
I just want to speak as it relates to the alternate assessment.
I want to share that we have had ongoing dialogue with the division.
And you'll remember from previous discussions that assessing this population with such unique learning needs is no easy task.
It's complicated.
And you'll remember that I came to a previous board meeting to applaud the way that the division was thinking about assessing
this population going forward as they are rolling out the alternate assessment for science.
The evolution in this discussion shows the desire on the department to create a strong link between curriculum and assessment, which is what we at the Advisory Commission have been asking for.
So, we really need this population to have an individualized way to capture what they know.
The cut scores, though, and the threshold scores really do need to realistically represent what this population has mastered as it relates to the standards.
We look forward to the continued dialogue with the division and appreciate Michelle's Center and her staff for continuing to engage us.
This is an evolution and we appreciate being involved and look forward to that ongoing discussion.
Thank you.
Board Member Rucker.
Okay, so I just want to say, having had the opportunity to actually observe a standard setting activity, that the suggestion or the concern that maybe we're not being transparent in providing the evidence or the data that's related to where this recommendation came from, I think that there's, I want to offer some comment to my colleagues on the board about that.
The people who sit in the room for the standard setting study the actual items on the assessment, they study the standards those items are supposed to be aligned to, and they actually take a look at and have a conversation about what they believe the item is supposed to be telling us about the performance of those students.
and the data that is being requested about the performance of those items, those members in those rooms see that information.
And so they are studying a lot of data, not only about the item itself, not only about the performance of the item, but they are seeing all of this data
that is being requested concerning what supports the underlying recommendation for these threshold scores.
Not only did they see them, but they argued about them.
And they argued about what they mean.
They argued about the differences in their interpretation.
And they came to some agreements, not compromise, but clear agreements about what it's supposed to mean and what setting those threshold scores mean.
And so there was vetting not only once by the grade level and even among the subject area, there was an effort afterwards when the work was done to have a secondary group also do that similar type of review.
So the kind of transparency that's being asked for actually would compromise the process.
because there is a lot of very confidential information, particularly about the assessment items themselves.
But the work that was done among the stakeholders who participated in that standard setting addresses the concerns that have been raised about the evidence upon which the threshold scores are being recommended.
Now, as to Michelle's recommendation to the board that we revisit it, classroom teachers do this all the time.
If I gave a test and 100% of my students got an A on the test, I need to think about if the test I gave was too easy.
Or if I give a test and 100% of my students fail the test, I need to think about whether or not the test I gave was too difficult.
So it is normal
to continually assess and evaluate whether or not how you are giving the assessment, but also how you are choosing to do the grading and the reporting on the performance of that assessment.
It is a realistic and common sense idea to revisit
Did the test do what we said it was going to do?
And are we providing real performance ratings that tell us realistically about what the test is doing for that student population?
So I think inside of the standard setting process, which cannot because of what it is the participants look at,
It cannot be transparent to the public, but inside of that process, all the data that stakeholders want to know is available and was reviewed.
It actually was reviewed.
Do you have any comment on the concern that this test is too difficult for the students?
The test measures adapted Common Core State Standards.
Adaptive?
They are adapted Common Core State Standards.
That is probably difficult for some students and I think it's also challenging because we don't yet have the curriculum that goes along with that yet.
So over time, I'm hoping,
And I'm so excited that Kristen Wright is your new division director over the special education division, because I know that we can work collaboratively together on that specific point.
So will it be this difficult a few years from now?
I don't know.
I think we should hope not.
I would like to comment, though, on the comment that there was, I can't remember the percentage, 30-something percent of students that could not orient to the test.
There were approximately 14 to 19 percent, depending on the grade level, of students that could not orient to this test.
So that is nowhere near the percentage that was mentioned earlier.
Okay, further comments on this?
Board Member Sandoval.
Thank you for the report.
I thought it was very clear and I felt that in addition to the materials that we had prior to the meeting, your presentation today answered some of the questions that I had.
I just want to recognize that this is a process and it's ongoing and we're learning as we go.
I think that there is more coordination and alignment.
The promise that the development holds for the alternate assessment for science with embedded performance tasks that inform instruction, there's more learning that's going to happen through that.
So I appreciate the work that's being done and the communication with the various stakeholders around this.
So thank you.
Thank you.
I'll move the item.
all right any further comment from the board hearing none all those in favor what yes sorry yes just on this the threshold on special ed yes just on special this is just special ed oh it's it is
I'm sorry, move, yes, the recommendation regarding the achievement levels for special ed.
Yeah, for the alternate assessments with the understanding that we will be revisiting these cut scores, these thresholds after a couple of administrations, okay?
Okay, all those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, now we're on to the other item.
Now on to the second action within this item.
We are seeking approval from the State Board on the proposed high-level test design for the California Spanish Assessment, also referred to as the CSA.
This new test will eventually replace the standards-based test in Spanish.
I think it is important to first talk about why we are asking for your action today.
We are here because the California Education Code says we are to identify a purpose for this test prior to its development.
Based on the law, we also must consult with stakeholders, including English language experts, to determine the purpose of the primary language assessment and then move forward with development.
The initial step in the process involved developing a high-level test design, which we are sharing with you today.
Intent language of AB 484 focused on assisting educators in improving instruction and providing students with every opportunity to learn.
This legislative intent is different than what we've ever done before in California.
We're now focused on having a more comprehensive assessment system with a primary purpose of improving teaching and learning rather than developing assessments that are built solely for the purpose of accountability.
To this end, we've put together a design team to work through the process of developing this high-level test design, which is attached to the board item.
The design team includes nationally recognized experts in linguistics, Dr. Kenji Hakuta and Dr. Guadalupe Valdez, along with ETS, our contractor, who has experts in assessment development, psychometricians, and research scientists on the team.
Based on the design team expertise and input, we are recommending the following test purposes.
Measure a student's competency in Spanish language arts and provide student level data in Spanish competency.
Provide a measure to evaluate rather than penalize the implementation of Spanish language arts programs at the local level.
And provide a high school measure suitable to be used in part for the state seal of biliteracy.
We are privileged to have Dr. Kenji Hakuta with us today to share key aspects of the high-level test design.
Dr. Hakuta is the professor of education at Stanford University, where he teaches courses in language development, bilingual education, research methods, and statistics.
His research is in the area of psycholinguistics, bilingualism, language shift, and the acquisition of English in immigrant students.
He is actively involved in supporting the work of school districts and states around the country,
And we have been fortunate to have him on our design team.
Welcome.
Hello.
I'm pleased to be here, and I'm sorry that my good friend and colleague from Stanford, Mike Kirst, has just stepped out.
I want to show him that I actually own a tie, and I have the ability to put it on, so I hope the record reflects that.
It's a real pleasure to serve in this advisory capacity for this important project.
I was just asked to speak to the high-level purposes for this assessment.
the privilege of working with lots of school districts around California, both large and small, and having observed sort of the language diversity situation in California over many years, and think that this test really fulfills many of the needs that are out there in the field.
One of the benefits is really recognizing the value of bilingualism and biliteracy, which I think the state is really a real leader for the nation.
around sort of the recognizing language issues that especially Spanish-speaking students in California bring to this, not as a deficit to be overcome, but rather as an asset.
And so I think just the pure recognition of having a high quality assessment that really measures this,
is really of great value.
The second point I want to make is that language development in any language really, what we really aspire to is to have literacy in the language.
And so really the ability to develop literacy at a deep level in Spanish and having an assessment to measure that is important.
Again, assessment, not for accountability purposes, but to inform instructional practices, I think is really important.
Many students come to this country from Spanish-speaking countries and just understanding what they're bringing with them in terms of literacy in the native language itself will be highly
helpful in informing the kind of programming that the students need.
And also, I think that being able to look at these results in combination with the ELA assessment.
So I think it's important to recognize that this is not
a substitute for, in any way, the English language arts assessment.
But to really think about this as truly looking at assessment or proficiency in both languages is really
recognizing the value of bilingualism.
So again, this is not a translation of English language arts assessment into Spanish.
It really is recognizing what value Spanish has is important, and that's reflected in the aspirations of the seal of biliteracy.
The seal of biliteracy, which California again pioneered, is being used all over the nation now in many, many states.
I think it really recognizes the true value of bilingualism among students.
And then finally, I think that part of the value is the flexibility that's afforded to local districts around the LCAP, that this could be easily included in those plans as a way of monitoring progress towards biliteracy.
So I think, you know, many of us think of the seal of biliteracy as sort of
equivalent to what you would do at the end of the process, you know, similar to the high school graduation and so forth.
But having an assessment that sort of takes a much broader sweep at the developmental progression at the lower grades and being able to assure that students are really progressing towards those goals of biliteracy, I think, is also important.
So, thank you for allowing me to share some of these points.
I think, Michelle, that's
Yes, a question for you from Board Member Rucker, and we're honored that you wore a tie today.
It's the first time I've ever seen you in one.
I know.
I want to make sure that you know.
Yes, it's memorable.
And what color is it?
What color is that tie?
It's a Stanford color, but I'm wearing a blue shirt.
Okay, so first giving honor to my board president, Dr. Kirst.
I've always been starstruck from the first time I met Mike, but let me just say I'm starstruck sitting here getting a chance to talk to you and listen to this presentation.
So thank you for being here today.
I do have a question for you on the biliteracy and bilingualism.
Not only is California was a leader in creating the state's ill of biliteracy, California also did something else that was unique to the rest of the country.
We actually created a certification for tribal elders to teach Native American languages to students
in our schools.
And so what I'm kind of, what is kind of left out of the conversation though currently on bilingualism and biliteracy are students who are the speakers of those languages as well.
How can we recognize that work
and that teaching in those schools and in those classrooms in this conversation as well.
So those students also have the opportunity to earn the state seal because I'm not really sure we have figured that out quite, or if we're reporting that, I'm not really aware that that data is available.
So I'm hoping that some of that can be incorporated in the conversation too.
Thank you.
I think it's, I'll step out of the assessment piece and mention, and I'd like to kind of recognize that the space around native Indian languages and how that's recognized publicly is really, it goes way beyond looking at
It really requires a view of literacy that has to do with sort of the identity and history.
And I mean, it just goes very, very deep into our
our kind of cultural heritage.
And I think it enters into a very different space, I think.
And I think it's, some of it has to do with the need to revive those languages, not just to, you know, because many of these languages have very, very few speakers left of it, or it's within certain domains.
And so I recognize the importance of that, but I think also that it's really a space that almost has to be looked at from a bigger, broader historical and cultural lens.
Yeah and so I know I could tell by the body language among the staff that there is some work that's being done in this and some recognition but I want to make sure because this is something that we are doing in California.
ESSA in its reauthorization created in the section concerning Native American and Alaska Native education also encourages this level of flexibility but I want to be sure by the way we define by literacy and the way that students can earn
that state seal.
I think we have to figure out ways to make sure we're being inclusive of that since we have, we did this back in I believe 2007-2008 under the previous governor's administration.
This was actually signed into law so I'm hoping that this is an opportunity for us as we go forward on this level on this particular policy area to make sure we're paying attention to this as well.
Thank you.
If you did a word search through ESSA for bilingual, there's only one instance in which it appears, and that's under the Indian languages part, yes.
Board member, who's next?
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Oh no, please come back.
An honor to finally meet you.
I've heard about your work with my former boss, Elia Pompa, for years.
So it's great to meet you.
I'm also a little starstruck, as I was with Dr. Kurz, because I cited him widely in the past.
I have a question.
You mentioned that you wouldn't recommend, I don't know if I heard this right, for accountability purposes, the assessment.
Is that what I heard?
I think you would have to think about that in the context of what you mean by accountability or how you want to shape the accountability system.
If it's NCLB style accountability translated into ESSA, that's a different kind of conversation.
And it's certainly not the intent of this to sort of fulfill something like that.
And I think accountability in the sense of are we making progress towards and can we make improvements in our programs that support Spanish language and literacy development.
this could certainly be a very useful tool.
And that's why I was putting that in the context of the local accountability plans, for example.
If that is truly a goal to support state-sealed biliteracy and you want to see whether students are progressing towards it, it could certainly be very helpful in that.
And there's truly a lack of
instruments out there to accomplish this and that's personally the reason I'm the most excited about this because that's going to provide the incentive for systems to really put resources into the early grades for Spanish language development and hopefully for other languages as well by setting an example.
Right.
Because I know that we're waiting for the final regs on assessments, but there is something on primary language assessments in ESSA.
And I was wondering how that would look if it was to be embedded into the accountability system.
Like there are students who are newly arrived ELs that would be exempt for a year from the SBAC.
So could this be one of the assessments?
I know that for local purposes, for instance, my son's in a dual-language program.
I would like to know, is he really acquiring Spanish with a high level of proficiency?
Right now, he's still at the Yo Sepo stage instead of Yo Se.
You know, so he definitely does a lot of the Chicano vernacular.
But I am wondering, in general, how this could be incorporated, if it can be incorporated into an accountability system.
Should it be incorporated?
So those thoughts would be greatly appreciated.
Yeah, I would say, you know, the larger context there too is, I mean, the technical issues around state plans and peer review and so forth, the technical requirements and so forth.
And I don't think that this is, that's part of the consideration here.
And that's, you know, again, I think outside the scope of the development of this, I believe it's more,
more you guys' job to figure out how things like this could be used.
Okay, any other board member comments on this item?
Do we have public comment on the item?
Do you want me to give you any more information on the test?
Okay, continue then.
Kenji just wowed you so much.
I know, next time I need action, I'm just bringing Kenji.
No matter what the topic, Kenji.
Next time, yeah.
So thank you.
Thank you, Kenji.
I want to talk about who would take this test, the target population.
So consistent with Ed Code, the design team identified the following target population.
Students receiving Spanish instruction in California.
Any student seeking to assess their Spanish-specific reading, writing, and listening skills.
So this would be students who are recently arrived as well as those students that are seeking the seal of biliteracy or a pathway to the seal of biliteracy.
And just want to point out that there are multiple pathways to that seal and this is not in any way to mean that this would would eliminate the other pathways to getting that seal in California.
So there were key assumptions that were developed by the design team and let me
as well as with the department.
The first assumption is that this test would be aligned with the Common Core Standards for English Language Arts in Espaol.
This is a translation of the Common Core ELA standards with linguistic augmentation.
So it is not simply a translation of our Common Core Standards.
So that would include things like an example I have here, since I do not speak Spanish,
is masculine and feminine articles for nouns.
That would be addressed in those particular standards.
Another assumption is that it will assess reading, writing, and listening.
Speaking is not currently a part of the assessment design, given the current difficulties with assessing speaking on these types of standardized assessments, but we'll continue to monitor the research in that area over the course of time.
Like other CASP assessments, the CSA will be a computer-based assessment.
We are proposing that it will be administered in grades 3 through 8 in high school.
Additionally, a focus will be on providing accessibility supports for students with disabilities similar to those that are provided for other CASP assessments, but that are appropriate given the construct that's being measured on this test.
This test is an optional assessment.
It will be developed to be fair, valid for the purposes that are outlined before you today, and reliable.
The proposed design does not utilize human scoring for this assessment.
This is the timeline for development.
It is very aggressive, you will see, and one of the six assessments that are currently under development.
you will see it gets to spring 2019 as the operational test.
One of the reasons we're able to do that is California did own quite a few reading passages that were used in our other tests, so we're able to reevaluate those passages to see if they're aligned with the Common Core Espanol and if we're able to use those passages.
So that's one reason we're able to be a little more efficient with this assessment and the timing that you see before you.
So in conclusion, I'm asking that you approve the proposed high-level test design for the California Spanish assessment, thus allowing for the development activities to continue as proposed in the timeline here.
All right.
No further comment.
Public comment then on this assessment item only.
Then we'll have public comment on the general presentation of assessment.
So any public comment on the English
and Spanish assessment.
Good morning, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, and I'm here representing the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
We are pleased with the work that's been done so far on the CSA and are also very pleased to see that CDE is working with two well-respected experts in the field of
Linguistics and also recognized as experts with regards to English learners, Drs.
Hakuta and Valdez, we're pleased to see that the department is working with them.
We support continuing the work on the CSA.
We think it's very important, especially in light of the increased number of dual language programs that are being established statewide.
We also look forward to a continued conversation about the role of the CSA in the accountability system, and with all due respect to Dr. Hakuta Kenji, we believe that there is a role of the CSA in the accountability system.
It will require additional discussion,
and it will require additional work, but we believe that now is the time to really take a look at what is the best policy with regards to assessing English learners, especially English learners who are not yet English proficient when they're only being tested with English assessments.
English assessments may not necessarily provide the most accurate, valid,
a reliable measure of what they can actually do academically.
So we look forward to continuing this conversation with CDE staff, NSBE staff, and we believe that this is a good opportunity to really begin discussing the whole policy assessment issue with regards to English learners.
Thank you.
Okay, hearing that, so I'd like a motion on this assessment.
One more speaker, sorry.
Good morning, surprise.
Karen Cadero Kaplan.
Okay, I was like, what title should I use today?
I'm San Diego State University professor and I'm also representing CABE as I'm on their board as a Director of Legislative Affairs.
And I just wanted to, I'm just glad I had the opportunity to be here today to speak in support of this.
It's exciting to, you know, working with the folks you are, with Kenji and Guadalupe Valdez, it's really exciting to see how that's informing.
So we do support the work of CDE and continuing the development of the CSA.
I do want to say right now, part of the work I'm involved in is the preparation of bilingual teachers, and we have a shortage of bilingual teachers.
And in order to address that need, we have to ensure that students in these biliteracy dual language programs, the seal of biliteracy is really important in that how do we document their achievement in those two languages?
And if the demand for the teachers is there, it starts in K-12.
So the question that you posed around how would this look in accountability, I think that is a larger discussion because what we're seeing right now, I just came from CTC and it's really exciting that as they're looking at how we need to open the pipeline, they made the decision today to not have the CSET waiver, I mean to re-implement the CSET waiver programs for elementary programs, right?
So that's part of a movement towards looking at, you know, how accountability works with what makes sense for programs and growth.
So I think as we look, as you look towards this with accountability, we need to consider the deeper discussions and what's the intersections with EL assessments, with Spanish language assessments, and then to the point of other languages, how would that look going forward?
So I think this is a historic moment and supporting this is really important.
Thank you.
Seeing no other public comment, I'd like a motion then on this assessment.
Go ahead.
I move approval of the Spanish language assessment process.
Would you like to do it?
No, that's not how you do it.
I move approval of a Spanish language development test, the design and process.
Did I get it, Judy?
You want to say it, then I'll move approval.
Okay, I move CDE's recommendation regarding the high-level test design for the California Spanish assessment.
I second that.
Okay, all those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, and I think now we will take public comment on the general assessment of CASP.
Thank you.
Good morning again.
I'm Doug McRae, a retired test publisher from Monterey.
I submitted two handouts to your electronic folder last week.
First, an August 9th set of comments on the California Peer Review submission to the Feds, as well as the Smarter Balanced Peer Review submission to the Feds.
That was an 11-page document.
The front page mentions the opportunity to learn issues that I've talked to you many times about.
But it also, on the Smarter Balanced peer review, quote, revealed, as they say, the technical report revealed some gaps in item coverage at the low end of the performance spectrum and means
Fundamentally, that hurts the precision and accuracy of scores for low-scoring students, particularly English learners and low-wealth and students with disabilities.
But more so, it compromises the ability of the tool to measure achievement gaps at this point until that flaw is corrected.
So, in addition to the Department capacity, the actual measure has a problem with respect to measuring performance gaps.
The second handout had to do with the August 24th release of the 2016 results, and on that
I included comparisons to other states.
One point I'd make on that is the extreme difference in grade 11 English language arts versus math.
I think it is due to unfortunate standard setting, performance setting, revisions made by the chiefs at the tail end of the panel process that lead to that thing.
I don't think there is that big a difference between English language arts and math at grade level.
Also, finally, the state-by-state comparisons for 13, there's a 14th state that's out.
There is some experience in there with respect to using other metrics, scale scores, for gain, growth, improvement, growth, whatever, that type of measurement, but lessons to be learned from other states.
Thank you.
Good morning, I'm Sheila Whitley and I'm here representing the California Teachers Association.
We've made so many needed changes for education in the last few years and our board and our staff at CDE is certainly to be commended for all of these efforts.
We've talked about some of them this morning, the Seal of Biliteracy, it's a wonderful way to recognize our students that have developed some skills that are much needed in California.
But as an educator, I am concerned that the report does not provide useful information for district sites and teachers.
Basically, board member Rucker has talked about some of this.
The data analysis that was done without some of this being usable data being available to sites, to teachers, it's very difficult for us to address the achievement gap of our most needy kids.
We're working on all of these with our LCAP data.
Really, the purpose of giving some kind of test is to help inform instruction and to help us do better to meet the needs of our kids.
We really need to know what we're doing well and what we need to focus on to do better in the classroom.
We ask you to defer this and to work with staff.
and the other experts to help us figure out a way to provide this data in a useful, meaningful way for educators.
Thank you very much.
Mr. President, members of the board, I'm Brian Rivas on behalf of the Education Trust West.
We really appreciated your discussion this morning about gaps and modeling and data analysis.
I would just ask that you consider one of the things that you could do in the spirit of closing gaps is articulate formally that it is your expectation that LEAs close gaps.
I think that would be a powerful incentive.
I wanted to lift up a general topic with regard to testing and assessment, and that is performance tasks.
We think that it's important for all students to demonstrate not only what they know, but also what they're able to do.
I think you're thinking along those lines already, but from an equity point of view, we want to highlight that it's particularly important for English learners.
to be able to demonstrate mastery of content across all subject areas.
So we'd ask that you please keep that in mind going forward as you think about things like the NGSS assessments.
Thanks.
Okay, that completes that item.
And so now we're on to the next item.
Pardon?
No.
Yeah, item five.
And so these are the consolidated applications.
And we're going to take these in two batches.
One where Eileen and Ting must recuse themselves.
And this is action
They're recusing themselves.
Okay, this motion one I'm asking for is on five consolidated applications.
Pardon?
Okay, well let me just announce them.
110 Arcadia, 931 Monrovia, 975 Natomas,
1268 San Marino, 1339 Soledad.
So you may proceed.
That's what we're talking about in this particular motion.
Yes, my name is Jerry Winkler.
I'm the Director for the Educational Data Management Division here at the CDE.
I have the privilege of reporting that we are
approving, or we're recommending for approval, 1,570 of the LEAs that have submitted consolidated applications.
They're all on regular approval.
We're recommending them for regular approval.
We don't have any that are on conditional approval.
So it's a rather easy board item, and quick.
Okay, so are there, we're ready then for a motion on, is there any public comment on this?
No, okay, we're ready for a motion on the five that I read.
I'll move approval.
All right, all those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, so our board members may come back and now
Yeah, we need action two.
And board member Ortiz-Lacon is recusing herself from motion two.
So motion two is to approve the remaining 216, 217 CONAPs except the five that we already approved in motion one.
So do you want to make any comment on these or no?
OK.
Any public comment on this motion?
No.
Do we have a motion of approval?
All right.
Seeing no further discussion, all in favor, raise your hands.
OK, now we have the regular consent items.
And we can get Felusa for those.
Yeah.
Okay.
You want to take a break now?
Yes.
1, 2, 3, 4.
We have a quorum, yeah, okay.
So we could take a, we could approve the consent calendar.
I move the consent.
Those are, and on proposed consent are items 6 through 11.
Is there any public comment on the consent calendar?
Pardon?
I'll second.
So we have a motion and it's been seconded.
All right, no public comment on that.
All right, let's raise your hands if you approve the consent items.
In that regard, and then I want to, before we take a break, call up Kristen Wright so that I could present her with our State Board of Education Certificate of Appreciation and Commendation.
Please come forward for your certificate.
There you go.
Congratulations.
We'll see you later.
All right, let's take a 10-minute break till 10 after 10.
you
1, 2, 6, 8, through 17.
None?
I move the consent.
I second.
Okay.
Any comments on the motion?
All those in favor?
Okay.
Now we are on individual waivers.
So item waiver number three.
Good morning Board Member Strauss and Superintendent Torlakson.
My name is Chris Druin and I'm once again the Associate Director of the Special Education Division.
Item 3 is a request by the Cypress Elementary School District for a caseload waiver for an RSP program.
This item was originally brought to us for July and we pulled it and rescheduled for September
Due to some concerns about the timing of the waiver, the waiver took place in the 14-15 school year.
The caseload exceeded in 14-15, but we did not receive it until the 15-16 school year.
We understand that there was a snafu in the District Administrative Office.
Apparently there was a personnel change in the Special Education Director, and that person thought that the Human Resources Department filed waivers, and the Human Resources Department thought that the Special Education Director filed the waiver.
They called us and asked if they could still file the waiver, and we looked at the rules around the timing, and it apparently qualifies under the rules for timing, so we said that they could.
We also, in going through discussions with board staff and our own staff and the CDE, identified some things that were of concern that we ought to look into
related to comments made by the teacher in this case.
While the teacher did not voice any opposition to the waiver, she did indicate that she did have some concern about the reporting of the numbers in the caseload.
And so we went back to the district and it gave us some time to go question the district about the caseloads for that 14-15 school year.
They were able to provide us with a report that indicated that confirmed the caseload exceeded 28 by one student and for 29.
We also got information about that teacher's KSOAD for 15-16, and the KSOAD was 27 for that year, so the KSOAD did remain below the required amount.
They also provided us with documentation that the aid hours had already been provided, given that there was a 14-15 waiver.
So we are recommending approval with conditions.
The standard one that we include in these has to do with assurance that they provide the aid time that's recommended.
And they actually, as I said, have increased the aid time from 3.75 to 5.75 hours.
recommending approval with that condition.
So do we have any comments from board members?
Member Sandoval?
Yeah, I looked at this one very carefully, and I appreciate you addressing the questions that I had about this particular case.
And I think that it is unfortunate that it took a whole year to get the proper approvals, and it doesn't make it okay to let time lapse because there are changes.
It's everyone's responsibility to make sure
that things are filed in a timely manner.
But there are no documented previous complaints in this particular case.
Not that we're aware of.
This is a waiver that's the only waiver they filed that we have in our records.
Right.
And they are below the minimum or the maximum caseload.
And they did provide the eight hours.
So with that information, I would move approval of the CDE's recommendation.
Any other comments?
Do we have a second?
Oh, are there speakers for this item?
Good morning.
Lorraine Richards, California Teachers Association.
And the main comments on this is similar to what was stated in that it's extremely late.
And I know it was expressed due to a processing error, or the technical term snafu was used.
But I think just no further explanation is really needed.
But it's extremely, extremely late.
So therefore, CTA is opposed to it.
Thank you.
Any more comments on the waiver?
And Barrecker?
So we look at these caseload waivers for this particular program all the time.
And while it is important that the waiver does need to be approved, I think we need to take a look at what seems to be a norm for what happens in these programs that create the conditions either by salutary neglect
or poor planning, poor monitoring, poor oversight that make these kind of waivers important.
And so it concerns me that in my entire tenure on the board, we regularly have to look at these kind of caseload waivers that happen not because of some emergency or some unanticipated activity in the program, but simply because of salutary neglect.
So I think it is incumbent on us to think about what is happening to the quality of the services that are being provided to these students when incidents like this occur.
Because even though the waiver is being granted, there is no accountability on the LEA to make sure that this doesn't continue happening or to understand the circumstances that led to this so that it doesn't happen again.
Because it's not a surprise.
when you suddenly discover that you have more students in your program than the caseload should allow.
That's something they do know or they do have a way of figuring out and understanding long before the need for the waiver occurs.
And so while at this level, at the 5,000 foot level, it's incumbent upon our responsibility
to approve the waiver.
I think we do need to start thinking about the fact that waivers like this create in districts a lack of responsibility or obligation to consider the quality of the program they're providing to the students, to consider what they are doing to the teachers who are tasked to provide this service, and to the teaching assistants who have to provide the additional support, and whether or not in the long term
that actually wears down not only the workforce but also in some ways detracts from the work we've already had a conversation on earlier about what contributes to closing the achievement gap for students who fall into this particular subgroup.
So we do need to think about what it means when districts continue to do this and continue to need this particular waiver because they are not doing the work they should do
to improve their workforce, to add to their workforce, and to take the steps to assure the waiver is not necessary.
We can't fix that by a failing, by denying the waiver.
And we also, I think we need to recognize we haven't solved the problem by approving the waiver either.
So I think, I'm hoping, and I've had this conversation with staff and I've asked them to have some conversations with these LEAs, particularly those who are the repeat offenders who continue to come back and ask for these waivers because they're clearly not doing the work they should be doing to prevent the circumstance from occurring.
Thank you.
Are there any other board comments?
And we have a motion and we have the second?
Okay.
So all those in favor of the motion?
Motion passes.
Thank you.
We're on to waiver four.
I'm going to take off on your comments because we're at Poway.
Yeah, no, you just set me up perfectly again.
It was great, thanks.
Pali Unified School District has an illustrious history of requesting RSP waivers.
They requested four waivers in 15-16, five waivers in 16-17, and two of those are today.
Most of those waivers are in different caseloads.
So there's only one that's a repeat in one school, but they are different RSP teachers.
So they don't violate, necessarily, any of the particular requirements that are in the waiver guidelines.
But they have a history over a couple of years.
There were a number of questions that we looked into and that were raised.
One, the teacher in one of these was identified as being on probation.
That's been a concern of this board previously.
That teacher is not on probation.
The teacher's been teaching in the district since 1998.
So we've verified that.
The teacher made comments about anticipating going over in the subsequent year, and she was thinking that she might be over as much as 32 students.
The district indicated in their response that they have overstaffed the schools this year, and I have more information about that in the next thing.
There was also a question about the term monitor only.
It appeared when they made the waiver application that they were sort of, in some way, almost excusing the overage by saying, well, some of these kids don't need as much service.
I understand.
So we questioned what monitor only meant.
They don't really have a good definition, and neither of the teachers that we contacted used that term when we questioned it.
They don't know that they have monitor-only students, if that's the case.
You may recall that in July, we added an additional
condition, and that condition was that the district report to us on their efforts to recruit and hire teachers, and we have some information from them.
One of our staff contacted Poway to get information about their efforts to recruit and hire RSPs.
They provided documentation about their recruitment efforts over the summer that predated the requirement from this board.
They have done a number of things in terms of job fairs, developing professional assistance programs, developing a program for mentored teachers, for new teachers, and also added an internship program to try to kind of grow their own, as it were.
As a result, they report that currently all positions are filled with the exception of one 40 percent RSP position.
They indicated that they are interviewing candidates, and they are confident that they will shortly be at 100 percent capacity.
This is as of the end of last week.
We are not happy that that's enough information.
We have asked them to provide us with a listing of all of the positions at all of the schools and indicate the caseloads as of this time, because as Member Rucker pointed out, they could be at 28 today and
be on the verge of going over.
So they have documented the provision of additional aid time and they have begun to complete the other recommendation.
We added the same recommendation again.
After your comments, I think that may be the same recommendation, which is to
document your recruitment and hiring efforts may not go far enough.
So we had crafted a proposal, again, that in case that came up in the discussion that we might offer to you.
And so we thought that the district, something like this might work better in this case.
And that would be the district must report monthly to the Special Education Division of the California Department of Education on the caseload of each RSP teacher in the district.
and actions they're taking to secure additional staff to support RSP teachers who are at risk for exceeding the maximum caseload.
And in parentheses it says, those teachers who have reached the maximum caseload of 28 students.
So that might be something that would be helpful.
I think that it through the if you don't mind, I think that at risk point is a good idea.
Because again, it's not a surprise when districts know that their caseload for their RSP programs are going to change because they know how many students are in the queue and under review in their student studies team process.
They know what the recommendations or the request from the student study teams are.
And even though we don't consider resources in making the decisions and evaluating students in student study, it is the district's responsibility to know whether or not they have the resources to meet what is being requested.
So they know if their programs are at risk of being over those caseloads because they know what's going on in their student study team process.
So it's a very clear idea in understanding what risk means.
So we're not asking them to link
the decisions they make in their student study team process to whether or not the resources are available.
We're asking them to be aware, knowing that they have students who could be placed in those programs, whether or not those programs have the resources available and they have addressed how they're going to do this if there is a gap.
So I think that that is an excellent idea.
Member Sandoval.
Yeah, when I was reading the rationale in the waiver request about
It said that, or whoever wrote the waiver request said that many students are on monitor status and it seemed to minimize the impact, right?
So what does many mean?
How many students are we talking about?
Would you clarify, first of all, just to follow up, you did a lot of research with the district, so could you clarify, do you know how many students are just on watch, probably watching consults, what that is?
So those were words that we got in the printed waiver.
When we called up subsequently to investigate that, as you asked this question before,
There was no answer because it isn't a real thing, I don't think.
The teachers didn't know what it meant.
They don't use that term.
So we could not get a number for you.
So that concerns me because even with the addition of the condition that you just mentioned, monthly reporting, I'm concerned about the accuracy of the reporting.
So, I don't know if, I mean, I appreciate.
So, Member Sandoval, do you think the conditions that the department's recommending will address your concern, or would you like to modify what the recommendation is?
Well, it's a question because if you ask for monthly reporting, but if we're not confident that we're getting accurate information, then what good is a report every month?
It occurs to me, and I don't know whether it's appropriate for me to engage like this, but I'm not always appropriate, so I'll just do it anyway, is that I think that should they make another waiver request, then we would need to perhaps go look at what they're doing and look at documentation on site.
We have, by the way, received a waiver request in a district that we are doing just that before we bring it to the board because it is so egregious that we are not comfortable even just making phone calls.
We're going to go look at records.
We're taking a team in and sort of swooping.
I mean, because the caseload caseloads are reportedly exceeding 36.
Oh, wow.
So it's, it's not, it's bad.
So we're, but in this particular case, respectfully, I would suggest that should they make another waiver request, then, you know, it's a new game.
So I just would like to add is that the students I believe that they're saying is monitoring is typically before a student is exited from the IEP, they often do full mainstreaming and they put them on what a district calls watch and consult so that they haven't lost the ability to pull them back in if they need extra special ed support.
So when you're checking on that, I think that's the kind of thing in addition to the monthly recruiting report that you're asking for,
Because that's the idea that the teacher is available and the aid is available to support, but the student is fully mainstreamed and they're not ready to fully exit them from the program.
And that may be what they're talking about as far as the teacher's not working directly with the student.
But monitoring still is time on that caseload.
And so it still needs to be considered.
I mean, we approved a waiver where the RSP teachers agreed that they were going to, instead of doing their paperwork during their contract time, that they were going to be doing that on unpaid time to make sure that they were maximizing their access to students during their contract day.
So, and I had concerns about approving something like that.
That's just crazy.
But even for students who are on whatever this term monitoring means,
It's time.
It's instructional time that's taken away from students that are on that RSP teacher's load who need the instruction.
So how much time is that?
How often is that done?
And how many students are simply being monitored?
But more importantly, since the RSP teachers didn't know that there are students on their caseload that they were simply monitoring, I suspect that's not what's happening.
So could you read what you're proposing the terms of the conditions would be from the department and then we'll see if the board wants to accept that or recommend any modifications or deny.
I would be delighted to.
Can I make one comment before I do that?
Yes, please.
I think that the way to look at the issue of monitoring both your comment and Member Rucker's comment is to pull the IEPs and look at what is written in the IEPs and to look at IEPs that go back more than one year, which we do through some of our monitoring processes to see if, in fact, it is a watch and consult kind of notion that they are exiting and making progress.
or whether it is some other thing.
But we can't really, I mean, without looking at the actual IEP note, many IEPs now are electronic and we can secure them without making a visit.
So I just wanted to, that's what a monitoring might look like in that issue.
So here's the wording that we kind of cobbled together.
The district must report monthly to the Special Education Division of the California Department of Education
on the caseload of each RSP teacher in the district and actions they are taking to secure additional staff to support RSP teachers who are at risk for exceeding the maximum caseload.
And then in parentheses it says, those teachers who have reached the maximum caseload of 28 students.
Okay, any more board comments on this?
Okay, do I have a motion?
Do we have public comments?
Do we have a motion?
I move that we deny the CDE's recommendation to approve this waiver.
Would you clarify, legal counsel, if we deny the waiver what does that mean?
This is a retroactive waiver so they have exceeded the caseload.
If you deny the waiver, I believe that means they get an audit finding, possibly?
We would need to find them non-compliant.
And then give them a corrective action.
And the corrective action could be something very similar to this.
So what's the impact for the district, just to clarify, Judy?
Well, if the waiver's denied,
and they've already committed to act, so it's likely that they'll get a finding from the Special Ed Division that they're out of compliance with the RSP Title V regulations.
And what the Special Ed Division usually does in that instance is set the district up on a monitoring plan.
Which is similar to what he's described with the monthly reports.
Is there any financial consequences?
Not that I'm aware of.
And remember, denying a waiver, part of the reason why we would deny a waiver is we are saying it's not in the best interest of the students being served in the program.
So I understand Member Sandoval's concern about denying the waiver, especially in the case of this LEA.
because even if they have 17 RSP teachers, if they file 17 different waivers for each RSP teacher that they've exceeded the caseload for, that is a system of salutary neglect and not monitoring
the program supports and resources that should be provided to these teachers and to those students.
And so what I'm hearing, and Member Sandoval don't let me put words in your mouth, is that there is a concern with this LEA, not with all of the RSP program waivers we've seen in general, there is a concern with this LEA that in continuing to ask for waivers, more than one,
And in one case, a repeated waiver that they are not acting in the best interest of the students being served in this program.
And that would be a reason for recommending that denial.
The denial, whether we approve the waiver with the conditions
or we deny it, the same outcome would occur because this LEA would be under an additional level of monitoring.
An additional level of monitoring if we approve the waiver with the conditions the staff is recommending,
or an audit finding.
The more formal process of denying the waiver, putting an audit finding on them, and then increasing the monitoring and auditing that the department is doing.
Either way, the LEA will be placed under an additional level of scrutiny to try to help them to correct what has clearly become a problem that they do not understand how to address.
So okay, I understand that the outcome would be the same, but denying it sends a strong message that you're a repeated offender and we now are not okay with continuing to just give you waivers without a consequence, correct?
So it's still the same outcome, but it's just the message that we're sending.
Is that?
I am seconding the motion.
Okay.
So now we have a motion and a second for denial of this waiver.
Do we have any more any more board comments on the motion?
Do we have any public comments on the motion?
No.
Okay.
All those in favor of the motion to deny this waiver?
The motion passes.
So I ask that if there are specific kinds of follow-ups that you would like as a board for us to do with this district other than what I've described here, could you convey them to us so that as we come back to address other waivers that we can update you on the things that have been done in this case?
So I just go back to Member Sandoval who lays on the special ed as well.
Is there anything beyond the conditions that you would like to ask the department?
The one question that I have again is who is on watch and exit?
I still haven't heard a number.
They should know who their students are.
We're in that status and the rsp teachers should know the same thing.
Oh, yes, they should Agreed, okay.
So, um, did you want to make a comment superintendent?
Okay Okay.
All right.
So we are now on to waiver five This is from union elementary school district
So this is the Union Elementary School District.
They have a history of submitting waivers.
They had one waiver in 14-15, three waivers in 15-16, and now we bring you two for 16-17.
The district has requested in the past two at the same school, but with different teachers.
Is this a rural district?
I think it's San Jose.
I'm not aware of any rural parts of the city.
Okay, so any other, so I guess I would ask you, is there any other clarifying details that would help the board inform their discussion beyond just the specifics of the last three years of waivers?
I think there's two things that should be noted.
Member Sandoval asked a question about fifth graders.
There's a thing about them indicating that in the future years that the caseloads would, on the natural, be reduced.
because of fifth graders moving from those caseloads at the end of the school year.
Pardon me, Member Rucker.
Did you want to make a comment?
Okay, go ahead.
I'm not defending it, I'm just stating it.
We did ask about the number of students who actually did matriculate and how those caseloads are looking now.
After the matriculation, the caseload in one of the elementary schools went down to 20.
and in the other it dropped to 24.
So that's just information.
That doesn't mean that it's the right thing to do.
I don't want to be confused with that, but we did inquire about that.
There was also an issue about the union opposing being contacted after the caseload is increased.
They feel that as other local union representatives that they ought to be consulted before the caseloads are raised, not afterward, as you've indicated before.
And the conditions that you've specified for this particular district?
We actually, I think on this one, put the conditions for hiring and reporting to us.
OK, Member Rucker.
Okay, so I want to go back to this matriculating.
There's a difference between students matriculating and students actually exiting the program.
So if they are matriculating, that means they're going to somebody else's caseload.
So they're solving their problem because the students are moving from their program to somebody else's program.
they have an obligation to work with the program they're sending those students to as well.
So all they're doing is solving their problem by transferring one problem from column A to column B. That doesn't really sound like really logical forward thinking or even responsible thinking.
But then the second question is, unless fifth grade is the only grade they teach at that school, there are other students who are moving up through and matriculating through those grades who will probably come up through the fifth grade and may replace those students who are leaving.
So they're still not thinking about what else their caseload looks like or who else could be matriculating into the program from their earlier grades.
I find that it's kind of like what Member Lincoln said about moving the chairs around until she can sit next to Board Member Holliday.
I have sat next to Board Member Holliday during board meetings, and it is a thrill that the rest of us should have an opportunity to have.
So in this case, I don't think they're actually doing not only some prescriptive thinking but some preventive thinking about how to address the workload of their students that will remain.
So I'm even surprised they put something like that in writing.
Wow.
Member Williams.
Member Sandoval, is both waivers and special ed liaison?
You're the waivers and you're special ed?
Do you have a, what is your recommendation regarding this?
I had one question, I was just waiting for the comments.
Okay, go ahead.
I just had a question about the discrepancy between the waiver application saying that the representative, the association representative had approved it.
But no, I thought it was a denial because they were consulted after it was signed.
So the paperwork that was submitted to the department says the union representative approved it.
We have, as a matter of course, as a result of our interaction with y'all, made calls to everybody who's consulted there.
We learned that they didn't oppose the waiver,
But they do not like the process that's being used.
They oppose that process.
They would like to be consulted, as you all have had discussion about previously, would like to have a process where they are consulted before the caseloads are raised.
So members Sandoval, do you have any more comments or clarification?
Okay, do we have any more board comments?
Any public comments on this?
Do we have a motion?
Hold on, we have a public comment.
Hi Jesse, come on forward.
Jesse Aguilar with the California Teachers Association.
The California Teachers Association opposes approval of this waiver.
We do not believe that high class sizes or caseloads are good for kids.
We believe that the individual attention that students need in order to be successful in school is sacrificed when class sizes or caseloads are increased.
In this particular item, the local teachers association was not notified until after the teachers had been contacted and had agreed to the increase.
strongly opposes this waiver and urges the State Board to deny.
Thank you.
Any other comments?
Do we have a motion?
I move approval of the CDE's recommendation with the conditions.
Do we have a second?
I'll second.
Any comments on the motion?
All those in favor of approval with conditions on this waiver?
Yes so we have one oh you're on okay it's approved it's approved okay thank you.
Thank you.
Okay so we are on now to waiver seven.
Good morning.
Good morning, Cindy.
Vice President Strauss, Superintendent Torlakson, and members of the board.
I am Cindy Chan, Director of the Charter Schools Division at the California Department of Education.
So this is a funding determination related waiver.
I'll provide you a little bit of background on funding determination because the waiver kind of is a first part process.
You'll see these three LEAs again because the funding determination is really what they're trying to get to.
So the three districts in this case requested a waiver for the charter schools that are listed on the attachment one.
Charter schools can't request a waiver on their own, so the districts did that on their behalf.
And what the waiver would do would waive portions of the California Regulatory Code, so Title V of California Code of Regulations.
And it's because these charter schools were delinquent in filing their funding determination requests, so that's what the waiver would do.
It would allow them.
to just start that process of filing the funding determination.
It would allow the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools to hear the funding determination and make a recommendation.
And then that funding determination would be brought back to the State Board for approval.
So I'd like to note the waiver doesn't generate money.
It doesn't do anything with apportionment.
It's the funding determination.
Yes, that will bring to you probably November, maybe January, depending on when they file the request and when the advisory commission can hear it.
So these three would allow them to get a funding determination or request one for the year in question.
For one of the schools, Yosemite Wawona Elementary Charter, they are actually asking for two years, but it's actually less than two years because they've requested August 18, 2014 through June 30, 2016.
And then the other two schools, Vantage Point Charter and eCademy Charter at Crane are requesting a funding determination.
for this year, so the waiver would be for the current year.
And I know that doesn't sound like it's late, but the way the funding determination timelines work, the schools would have had to come in the year before.
Yeah, it's just kind of different.
So all three of them ended up filing late, so they're here before you, just to get their foot in the door.
Now, if you don't approve the waiver, that means that their funding determination cannot be heard, so they would get zeroed out for their average daily attendance, that's what the funding determination does, for the year in question, which means they wouldn't get any LCFF money for that year, anything that's ADA-driven, lottery, state special ed funds, anything that's
driven by attendance would be considered zeroed out.
So that's the sort of the penalty for the schools by not getting the waiver.
Do we have other, member Holiday?
I will move to recommend the CDE's recommendation.
These are very small schools and we do need to hear the funding determination, understand what their problems were.
And so what this waiver does is allow us to hear it in November.
So I would make that motion if there's no speaker.
Okay, Member Williams.
Well, I'll second the motion, but it also allows Member Holiday and I to hear it at ACCS where we can pre-hear it and ask more questions than there might be time for at the board meeting as well.
Member Rucker.
You know, a lot of times, especially with the timeline waivers for these funding determinations, it is about the relationship between the charter school and the LEA.
That's the authorizer who has to file on behalf of the school.
So I can understand on a year-to-year basis why the schools or the charters need to make the request for the waiver on the timeline.
So for the two school sites that are making the request for the single year and it seems like they're not late, I understand why they are late because of the timeline when they should have made the request.
But for the school site that's asking for the two full years, I don't understand how that happened.
So this one, this is just the way the funding determination kind of works, the process.
So the school's first year of operation was 2014-15.
That's the year they need it, but the advisory commission can only grant a funding determination for a minimum of two years.
So unfortunately, they have to ask for two years, but they don't need the second year.
Right, so I asked that question on purpose so that that could be explained.
Yes, I asked that question.
So it didn't seem like we were bending over backwards to create an exceptional exception, but it's the circumstance not creating something different.
So yeah, I asked the question for that reason.
That's a little piece of the narrative that was not quite made plain.
So are there any other board comments or clarifications?
So any comments from public?
Good morning, my name's Angela DeRamos.
I'm here for the California Teachers Association.
I'm also a classroom teacher and just listening to all the discussion over the last two days, this is a complicated process.
I think of it a lot like rocket science.
Well, in my classroom I think of it like herding cats, but for our purposes and launching a school especially, it is really complicated.
And as rocket scientists and as me as the pilot, I'm relying on my administration and the people who are laying the groundwork
to be on the launching pad, the ground crew, to get everything in order, ready to go.
I need fuel.
I need my conditions.
I need my trajectory set on time in an orderly manner, or else we have a failure to launch.
And what we have here is a failure to launch.
And for that reason, we recommend to oppose.
Oppose the waiver?
Yeah.
Because it's not on a timely manner.
And we need, if the funding sources and all the requests need to be done, and they know it in advance, and we're expected to teach these children, then these things need to be done in a timely manner.
And they had an adequate warning.
Ignorance is not an excuse, especially in something as important as education.
Thank you.
Good morning, I'm Colin Miller with the California Charter Schools Association.
I did want to just note that the issues in these waivers are regulatory issues.
The timelines are very restrictive in the regulations, as well as the consequences of not meeting these timelines, which is essentially a zero funding for the entire school.
They seem a little bit out of whack with the situation where schools may or may not miss a timeline for whatever reason.
This is an administrative process.
one that focuses on the educational program of the school or the charter itself.
We have over the years strongly supported taking a crack at these regulations so that these issues don't even have to come before you because they are fairly simple and maybe creating some flexibility in the regulations around these timelines so that these situations aren't always in front of you.
would probably save schools and the department and you a lot of time and effort and still meet the intent of this law, which is to monitor the funding of these schools in a reasonable way.
But definitely support the opportunity to look at these regulations and look at ways that maybe they could be a little more streamlined and a little more effective.
Thank you.
Eric Remack, Charter Center.
I'll say ditto to his remarks.
None of these three are members of our organizations, but my understanding is two of the three are what you might call dependent district-run charters.
And what we often find is that with the district-run charters, they've got so many other things going on that they tend to lose sight of this irregular process that occurs once every x many years.
And the third one, I think, is a five-student school that serves primarily Park Service employees in Yosemite.
And you can imagine what it would be like to be an administrator of a school with five kids in it.
So thank you.
Thank you.
Member Holliday?
So I move the CDE recommendation.
Member Williams.
Second.
Just to clarify, if we approve this, Member Holiday, it will go to ACCS for full vetting of the approval.
Okay.
Do we have any comments on the motion?
All those in favor of the motion to approve?
Passes unanimously.
Thank you.
I believe that ends our waiver items and now we move to public hearing.
So we are moving to item 12.
Good morning, Larry Shirey, School Fiscal Services Division.
This item involves a request to transfer two parcels from the Santa Clara Unified School District in Santa Clara County to the Cupertino
Elementary and Fremont Union High School District and the County Committee's disapproval of that request.
I think I want to start off by just describing the situation first.
If you're following along on your laptops and the item, page two of the attachment one of the item has a map that looks like this.
I don't have it on, but it's a page from the County Assessor's book that shows the glory at a circle.
a little circle of 45 homes, and it shows the boundary between the districts that drops down and cuts two of those homes out of the Cupertino and Fremont school districts.
If you go to the next two pages, you'll see a map from the County Office of Education and a map from the U.S.
Census Bureau, which shows a different boundary and shows that these properties are in the Cupertino and Fremont school districts.
What this means is that these two homes, for local educational purposes and for federal U.S.
Census purposes, have been considered to be part of the Cupertino and Fremont School District for at least 40 years now.
Kids who've lived in those homes have attended Cupertino and Fremont.
And everybody thought that that's the district it belonged to.
It wasn't until one of the homes went up for sale recently that they found that it wasn't in Cupertino and Fremont.
So the owners of these properties petitioned the County Committee on School District Organization to transfer into the Cupertino and Fremont to formalize what's been going on for 40 years.
And their reasons were, this is a fairly discreet neighborhood, and we think we should be part of the neighborhood for all reasons.
And you know, we've been doing, and we have been part for 40 years, so this is not something that we're really changing.
The county superintendent, I should say that the Santa Clara Unified supports this, supported that transfer, but it was opposed by Fremont and Cupertino primarily because
Both Cupertino and Fremont are high-achieving districts, and they have constant pressure from parents who live outside the district wanting their kids to attend schools in the district.
So they see a lot of inter-district transfers and territory transfer requests, and they have for a long time.
The County Superintendent, in his recommendation to the County Committee, agreed that the conditions that needed to be met for this transfer were substantially met and that found some compelling reasons to transfer the territory.
We've already discussed those, the issue of the discrete neighborhood and the issue that's been going on for a long time.
However, the county committee decided to disapprove it, and their reasons for disapproving it were, one, they didn't believe the two parcels were sufficiently geographically isolated from Santa Clara Unified, and they really couldn't come to any agreement about whether or not property values were affected by this transfer.
It was a 4-4 vote.
As you know, when you're going, affluent school districts can have some effect on property values.
We are agreeing with the county superintendent and we're asking you to reverse the county committee's action to disapprove the territory transfer.
We're also saying, recommending that there's no reason to expand the election area from these two properties.
The default election area would be just the two properties, but we don't see a reason why anybody else needs to vote on it.
But if that's the case, if you take our two recommendations to reverse the county committee's action,
to retain the two properties as the voting area.
No election will be held because for election purposes, the property or the territory is considered uninhabited.
So your taking of our recommendation, which is to reverse the County Committee action, keep the election area as the two properties in question, will result in the territory transfer being finalized.
Member Williams.
So there have been children in those homes?
There, I think there's one child right now but there have over the last 40 years there have been children in those homes.
That went to the Cupertino School District and Fremont?
And Fremont.
Graduated.
But Fremont, I'm just asking for clarification here, Fremont and Cupertino both said that they wanted to deny allowing them to continue?
They feel true.
I mean, there's no one attending the districts right now.
In the past, they have attended Cupertino and Fremont.
Currently, there are no students in these two properties that attend Cupertino or Fremont.
So where does the student in the one student that is in one of those homes go?
I believe he is going to a private school right now.
The parent is here if you want clarification of that.
Okay, but for the last 40 years, whoever, if there were students there, they've gone to Cupertino and Fremont, but Cupertino and Fremont's reaction now is don't want to let them continue doing that because we have too many others that are always asking us to come in.
Right.
In the past, they thought that those territory, those homes were in their district.
Now that they discovered that they actually aren't, they are concerned because of the past history of getting a lot of requests to transfer into the districts or inter-district transfers into the district.
They think that approval of these properties would set a precedent for the county committee approving future requests.
But just one more clarification, the kind of request they typically get is let my kid come in from out of district.
It's not let my home be considered a part of the Cupertino district.
That's what makes this different.
Right.
And the Cupertino District as a basic aid district, they have said that they would take the students from these homes on interdistrict transfer.
Fremont Union High School District hasn't agreed to that.
But for the most part, both Fremont and Cupertino, as do most basic aid districts, they pretty much turned down all interdistrict transfers.
And it's just two homes?
It's just two homes.
Okay.
Yeah.
Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
This was fascinating.
Kind of took me back to my urban planning days.
My masters I never used.
But my question is, one, I don't think this realtor will ever be hired again in this community because he made such a discovery that created all this.
If we were to reverse the decision, what can happen?
Can they appeal?
Is there?
Were it?
You're it.
It will just be filed with the State Board of Equalization.
Information will be sent back to the assessor's office and the registrar.
It's a done deal.
And the district's concern is that others will try to follow suit.
But because this is a contiguous community with an identity and it meets some of the specs or some of the requirements, it would be really difficult for others to try to petition in a similar way, correct?
Well, yeah, it's not difficult to petition.
But to be approved.
Right.
And, you know, the county committee has just a little quick background.
Santa Clara County Committee has probably dealt with
I don't even know what the county is, but over the past 20 years, this board has heard 24 appeals of its decisions regarding attempts to transfer into districts that are considered very affluent in Santa Clara County.
Palo Alto, Cupertino, Los Altos, Saratoga, Los Gatos.
Those districts get a lot of these requests.
In fact, I've got three more for you next year of county, in those districts that you'll hear.
County committee turning it down.
So, our point is that the county committee's dealt with a lot of these.
They turned down almost all of them and most of them get appealed up here.
They do approve a handful for valid reasons like we think they should have done here.
So, in terms of us supporting the idea that this would set a precedent, we disagree with that for two reasons.
One is this is very narrow set of circumstances.
that is not going to be a general precedent elsewhere.
Also, the county committee in the past has not shown an inclination to use its prior approvals as a precedent to approve them.
They disapprove most of the ones that come to them.
All right, so I just want to be clear on understanding why the county committee for these two homes that have previously had students attending the school districts without an inter-district transfer, and they're the only two homes on Glorietta Circle that are not in the district,
I'm lost on the rationale on why they said no, because this is important to me.
And this board has a long history of supporting the local decisions of the local leadership.
So it strikes me that the two school districts that would receive these homes are saying that they don't want it, but I'm confused.
Yeah, that's partly my fault.
I was at Santa Clara County Office of Education up until about 2000, so I was working with the Santa Clara County Committee on territory transfers and dealing with these issues.
And, you know, we had a huge, huge concern, county committee as well as districts, about what we've just been talking about, this
numerous, numerous requests to transfer territory into Los Gatos or Saratoga, Cupertino, Los Altos.
And the county committee needed to come up with a way to handle those issues.
So they did a whole area-wide study, and what they came up with is that, you know, the county committee has nine conditions that it has to look at.
The condition in question here is a community identity question.
There are a lot of factors that this board has established through regulation that the local folks need to look at when
uh, ruling on that county, that community identity issue.
One of them is geographic isolation.
So what we had worked out with the county committee 20 years ago is that, you know, it's very, very difficult for small territory transfers not to substantially meet all the, all the required legal conditions.
They're going to be met.
but it's not a rubber stamp to approve the territory transfer.
The county committee has to find a reason to transfer the territory.
We also, back 20 years ago, gave the county committee a reason not to approve territory transfers, which was, you know, if it's not sufficiently geographically isolated, then you can use that to deny a territory transfer.
For whatever reason, the county, in my opinion,
For whatever reason, over the 20 years, the county committee has morphed that geographic isolation into the community identity condition, which is a condition established by the legislature and as regulated by state board.
So in our mind, in our opinion, they are misusing that condition.
We called this out before, last year when we had a territory transfer, and we'll call it out again three times, I would imagine, next year when we have these appeals.
So, the county committee's concern, fed by the district's concerns of establishing a precedent, not wanting anything to come into their district,
They disapprove these things based primarily on this geographic isolation condition.
And in this case, they also looked at property values and they split 4-4 on that because again, their concern and the district's concerns are if you transfer the territory into Fremont, Cupertino could increase the property values.
And the condition is you can't, in code is that the territory transfer cannot primarily be for that reason.
In this case, we don't see how it can primarily be for that reason.
They have been considered part of the Cupertino-Freemont School District for 40 years.
Property values would have gone along with that line.
The only thing that may occur now is that people find out that the properties aren't in the district, property values will drop.
If you transfer, then it just comes back to what it's always been.
So we don't see that as being even increasing property values, let alone transferring the property for that purpose.
I actually appreciate the clarification because I read through the document and I you know the night before we started the board meeting on a Tuesday and I got up again and I read through this item even though it wasn't going to be on Thursday's agenda because I was just lost on
how the County Commission went on a different path around this.
So explaining that in the way you did is very helpful.
And it brings back to mind when I was in elementary school, my friends and I used to sit around and discuss, how is it possible that it could rain on one side of the street?
And this is a conversation about how is it possible for rain to happen on the other side of the fence?
So I actually understand now how this actually occurred.
And I do agree with the explanation you've given about where the fault or the gap is in their logic.
So no, I actually do appreciate that.
And if I could take myself back to being in fifth grade, I could now answer that philosophical question to my friend.
Member Holliday, thank you.
Yes, I am the liaison to this and If you did not see the letter that is in your box, please take a look at the letter Why don't you clarify said that so that people know I'm sorry.
It's a no no just so the public Michael curse president and it comes from the secretary-designee to the Santa Clara County Committee and
and reorganization.
And they express lack of opposition to the CDE recommendation.
So my recommendation though would be that we open the public hearing because we do have speakers for that.
And then we can continue the conversation after that.
Okay, any more, Mr. Shirey?
Okay, so now the public hearing is now open and we have, I believe, is it 10 minutes?
For those in support of the CDE recommendation.
Hi, I'm Charlie Peters and this is my neighbor.
Hi, I'm Ranjit Monkekar.
We appreciate the time that you're taking to consider our appeal.
We're open to any questions.
Did you want to make any other comments?
In general, we support everything that's there in the document, and we're here if you had any more questions.
We thought we'd come here in person.
So you two are the homeowners of the two houses in question?
Forty years.
Three years.
Okay.
So you're the one that discovered it?
The three-year one?
Okay.
And the 40 are your kids went to the school?
I like the team shirt, so.
I realize that I'm the most underdressed guy in this room, and I didn't wear slacks, so I'm sorry.
Okay, member Linko, did you want to ask a question?
Homeowners.
The strange thing is, if you look at the map, it's not a circle.
It's more of a horseshoe.
And we're right at the end of the horseshoe.
OK, that's all.
But we appreciated you coming forward and clarifying.
Is there any more?
Member Williams?
I just want to make a comment.
My kids with I now live in San Diego, but I raised my children through the Cupertino School District and Limbrook High School.
So as I look at the map and I think about the issue, I'm frankly just a little bit appalled that Cupertino and Fremont are recommending against it.
You know, it doesn't make any sense on any level.
Okay are there any more in support?
All right and do you all have any more to say because you have 10 minutes so okay.
All right then okay then I declare the no no now I have 10 minutes for the opposition.
You two may sit down.
Do we have anybody here to speak against this?
I'm hearing none.
I now close the public hearing.
Okay.
So now, Member Holliday.
So once again, my sincere thanks to Larry and his team because in our conversations and in the liaison calls, it's so obvious and so clear that Larry has tremendous knowledge about these sorts of situations, tremendous years of experience, looks at all these things carefully, unbiasedly,
Tries to understand and give us his best judgment.
And in this case, I think he certainly has done that Also, we do not have a history of denying the local Decision we have a history of supporting the local decision in so many cases I think this was just a slip and and I think we need to just move beyond it.
So I would move that the staff recommendation I would second
Okay, do we have any other board comments on the motion?
Do we have any public comments on the motion?
No?
Okay, all those in favor of supporting staff recommendation?
Okay, passes.
Thank you.
Congratulations, gentlemen.
Thank you for coming.
Okay, we are on to item 13, and this is also going to be a hearing.
Cindy Chan, please come forward.
Hey, good morning again, Cindy Chan, Director of the Charter Schools Division at the California Department of Education.
So International Studies Language Academy, which I will refer to as ISLA in my presentation, is a current state board of education authorized charter school and is requesting a material revision to its charter from opening in the current year, 2016-17, to delay it to open in the 2017-18 school year, so for one year.
ESLA was scheduled to open by September 30th, 2016 in the Glendale Unified School District boundaries.
However, due to difficulties it has had in securing facilities, ESLA is requesting to delay opening for one year.
ESLA submitted its material revision request on June 15th, and the CD has reviewed the revised petition and all of the documents that were submitted.
And the CD is recommending that the State Board hold a public hearing and thereafter approve with one condition and two technical amendments the request for material revision to the ESSA petition.
The recommended condition is that ESSA must adhere to the terms and conditions as noted in attachment six of the item, State Board of Education standard conditions on opening and operation.
So typically a material revision request would first go to the advisory commission on charter schools and they would hear the information and form a recommendation and then you would receive two recommendations, one from the CDE, one from the advisory commission.
But the August ACCS meeting was canceled due to
a lack of a quorum.
And there is a September 30, 2016 due date or deadline that the school is facing.
When they were approved in May, that was the condition.
They had to open in the current year by that date.
So we had to bring the mature vision request to this meeting in order to meet that deadline.
And that's why there's no ACCS recommendation in this case.
So give me a little bit of background about the charter school, just sort of refresh your memory.
ESLA was originally denied by Glendale Unified School District and the Los Angeles County Board of Education on appeal.
ESLA appealed to the state and was approved by the state board at its May 2016 meeting for a five-year term to serve up to 1,056 pupils by its fifth year in transitional kindergarten through grade eight.
ESA will implement a dual immersion program for TK through grade five in four targeted languages, German, Spanish, Italian, and French, and an immersion and acquisition language program for grade six through grade eight, offering the four languages.
If you recall, if you recall at that May meeting, there was some discussion, I think it was a little bit of confusion as to specifically what languages were going to be offered for each grade level serve.
The petition wasn't that specific enough.
So as part of the material revision, ESA revised that part of the petition to reflect its anticipated enrollment by grade level and what languages would be offered for each grade level.
The CD finds that the ESA material revision petition meets the standards and criteria requirements.
And I know I quote that a lot, that's from the statute.
And what that means is that the same requirements that we use, which are very rigorous, that are used for an establishment of a new charter, which is an appeal that's usually here,
Those same criteria and standards apply to a material revision.
So we look at the petition, we look at a new budget, we look at all the supplementary documents that the school submits.
And this also includes whether the petition provides a reasonably comprehensive description of the multiple required elements.
In this case, we find that it does with the two technical amendments that we are proposing.
Additionally, the financial plan submitted by ISLA was reviewed and appears to be sustainable and fiscally viable.
So again, as a condition of ESLA's original approval, the charter school is required to open by September 30th of this month, unless the state board deletes or extends that deadline.
Keep in mind, the delay in opening does not extend the charter term.
So the charter was approved for five years.
That remains intact.
So they're only going to be able to operate through June 30th, 2021.
The current year would serve as a planning year for this school, so that would just shorten the amount of years of operation from five to four.
So as you begin your deliberation, I would emphasize that the action before you, as a reminder, is to approve or deny the material revision request.
And that's primarily to allow the charter school to delay opening for one year.
Your action today is not to approve or deny the charter school.
That was already considered back in May.
That was deliberated on and the result was that the school was approved.
And so now that school is under the oversight of the state board.
However, this is a little complicated because most material revisions don't have a result as this one.
I would note that denial of the material revision request would effectively terminate the charter.
as ESLA would be unable to open by September 30th and that was a condition of its original approval.
So that is something to keep in mind as you're listening to the presentation and any questions you have.
So to quickly summarize, the CD recommends that the State Board hold a public hearing and thereafter approve the request to revise the ESLA petition to extend opening for a year from the current year to 2017-18 with the CD's recommended condition and two proposed technical amendments.
Representatives from ISLA and the Glendale Unified School District I believe are here to address the board.
Okay, thank you Cindy.
Do we have any liaison comments or should we before we go to the public hearing?
Just quickly, Member Holliday and I both agreed and felt comfortable with having this charter come with this material amendment now, even though it was unable to go to the ACCS because the ACCS was on vacation.
We couldn't get a quorum.
So we feel comfortable with it coming now and with what we think needs to happen with it.
So our technical assistance, sir, this is this is from our earlier item.
So do you want to prepare it so that we can see the correct presentation?
That's right.
Thank you.
So we'll now declare the public hearing open and the petitioners have 10 minutes.
So welcome back.
Good morning.
Hello, everyone, members of the Board.
I'm very excited to see Superintendent Torkelson here.
Is that better?
Because it's a treat for me.
So I'm Gillian Bonacci.
I'm one of the co-lead petitioners for ISLA.
And if you recall, we were here in May and we received our authorization.
What has happened in the meantime is that we have secured a facility in Glendale and we're requesting this material revision because in the analysis of the property we determined that we won't have enough time to build it out properly for a September opening.
That is the only change that is in this material revision except for the CDE required technical amendments and conditions from May.
So this is the only thing.
So we did secure the facility this summer and we came to realize in June that the city of Glendale was going to require a CUP for that particular location.
We intend to file a CUP request as soon as we get the decision from this body.
We understand that the process could take four to six months, which includes the appellate time frame if needed.
We've retained a land use attorney, an expediter in Glendale to assist us with the process.
So we believe that the CUP process would take us to about February if it goes to full length, February of 2017.
So concurrently with filing the CUP, we would, our architects, they've already done an initial review of the property and the surrounding area and they haven't discovered any obvious
you know, underground gas tanks or things that would prevent a school from being located in that area.
We'll begin our phase one environmental study and as soon as, you know, as soon as we file the COP, we'll start working on our plan.
The architects will work closely with the city planning department to identify and rectify any possible issues along the way.
And we've already identified traffic and noise engineers to do the traffic and noise studies for that area.
Also, while we're gonna be going through the CUP process, we will start with the mechanical drawings and the process of working with the city planner and the architects will be happening concurrently.
So, as soon as the CUP is granted, which we would hope will be February of 2017 or sooner, then we will begin our tenant improvements.
The architects estimate the build-out timeframe to be three to four months, and that would get us to June 2017.
So, we feel very comfortable with the timeline.
added padding for an appellate timeframe.
Our architects have given us very initial approval of, they think the building looks good, it's a fairly new building, so they don't feel like there's any large structural things that would have to happen.
We feel like this is a very positive path that we're following.
In the meantime, as soon as we get the answer from this board, we will restart our recruiting and our outreach efforts that we had paused back in June.
We will contact all of this year's applicants to gauge their interest for next year, although, frankly, they've been contacting us, so we know that a good number of them are still interested.
We intend to use Facebook marketing, some door-to-door advertisements, which now that we have the facility, we have the neighborhood, that was something that had held us up previously.
Outreach to preschools, churches, language academies, the YMCA, cultural institutions, consulates, various engaged parents like to have house parties, invite their friends to get the word out.
farmers markets, street fairs, you name it.
A lot of these things were not available to us back in May because of the lateness of our authorization.
So now we have a full year.
And we have a lot of very activated parents, very motivated.
They really want to come to work and help us bring in students.
We've kept our job postings up on EdJoin and we've continued to receive new applicants for teachers and for a principal.
So we'll continue through that vein as well.
Our contingency is that we will continue to search Glendale for alternative properties just in case something should be discovered that would make this property unsuitable for us.
And then we will file Prop 39 requests just because of the timing, because it's due at the end of October.
But we'll do that concurrent with the CUP process.
Do you have any more as part of your presentation?
Okay, do we want to ask questions now?
We want to wait for the, okay, maybe we'll have, we'll wait for, okay, so now we'll have all those, but I think I have to close this part, right?
No, okay, so, okay, opposition for the material revision.
Good morning State Board of Education, Superintendent Torlakson and staff.
My name is Wilfred Robertson and I am the proud superintendent of the Glendale Unified School District.
I'm here because this issue and matter is very serious to us, a matter of capacity and our analysis that we would like to raise before the State Board of Education to truly interrogate the capacity of the charter to serve students.
I'm here as a steward
of the well-being of students and their success, just as the State Board of Education is.
And there are serious concerns about the ability of this charter to serve students as described.
I am not an opponent of charters.
In fact, while in Davis, we opened one, a very successful one.
And I know the State Board is about supporting successful charters.
This is not one.
and because there are serious capacity issues.
As we described, when our team came before you, we stated that this would happen.
And so, the revision is back here because the capacity to open was not there on the facility.
I know Glendale very well and I know the real estate and the property as described is currently a Korean market.
And I do know that that lease is not open up until June of 2017.
Hear what I'm saying?
Could you clarify what you just said?
It's currently a Korean market.
It is currently a Korean market.
There will be serious revisions to make that property habitable to serve students in an environment that is conducive for learning.
Other capacity issues that we're concerned about is the fact that this is a dual language program.
And when a program fails, if a charter fails, and this one has all the implications of not being able to succeed because of fiscal, as well as the description of students, the number of students that they anticipate
being able to serve and to start a dual language immersion program with four languages over six grade spans is ludicrous.
I hate to use such a strong term, but pedagogically, if you look at what Glendale has done in serving students with dual languages, we really have the model on this.
And we know what it took for us to open.
We didn't open with that many languages, with that many grade levels.
And we have the fiscal capacity to do it.
We had teachers.
It is tough to recruit teachers for this.
We deal with that.
And we pay better.
So we have serious concerns about this.
I look at this, and this is about the students that we are stewards over.
It is not about anti-charter.
It is about how do we best serve students.
It is, as doctors take the Hippocratic oath, stating that they would do no harm.
When students in the dual language program are not able to continue
they lose different from students that are in an English-only program.
That's why I'm asking that the State Board of Education truly interrogate your staff as well as this particular charter revision.
Because if it fails, it is not students coming back to our public schools from an English-only program, but the language loss and the malpractice
is going to show up even greater.
So now, as we stated, we knew that this was going to happen.
We have concerns about the ability to secure the property.
We've done our homework and research and know what it will take to take a permit through the city of Glendale.
And it's more like four or five months.
But the property is currently being used.
So if the State Board of Education approves this material revision, we expect that the ISLA will be back at this podium many times this year asking for additional revisions when they realize they cannot enroll their stated number of students, when they realize they can't find a viable location in Glendale, and when they realize that it is not feasible to open a charter
with dual language grades K through five, not this many number of grades.
So I'm asking that the State Board of Education seriously interrogate this charter and its capacity to serve the students that we have swore to serve.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm Cheryl Plotkin, and I am interim chief business officer and financial officer for Glendale.
And I was asked on coming in to look at the budget that was put together for ISLA.
And this is my credentials.
I am a CPA, I'm a former auditor, and I've been 13 years as CBO.
I looked at it and said, if this were a school district, you would never approve it.
And the thing I was looking at most was their cash flow statement.
First, I analyzed their revenues, which I said are overstated.
First of all, they're saying they're going to have 55% free and reduced lunch.
They modeled themselves after Franklin.
Franklin only has 35% unduplicated students.
They only have 20% free and reduced lunch.
This is not a type of school that is going to get 55% unduplicated students.
Without that, they lose $560,000.
They also would not have Title I. That is another $97,000.
In their budget, they put lottery, which they wouldn't receive for another year.
That's another $76,000 that comes out of the revenue they're showing on their budget.
In their budget, they're saying they're going to have 438 students.
However, in a public meeting they held,
They already are talking about going down to the 328, which is the allowable 20 percent.
So they are already looking at getting less students.
I don't know what that would cost them in the way of money.
Obviously, they would lose LCFF money.
But they might have offsetting teachers' reductions.
But if you are offering four languages,
and all those classes, you would either have to reduce the number of grades you're serving or the number of languages you're serving in order to go to less students.
I looked at their cash flow.
In their narrative, they said that they would only need to borrow $650,000.
But if you just look at their cash flow statement, they say they have to borrow $766,000 in the first year, $697,000 in the second year.
and $409,000 in the third year.
But if you add the revenue that is overstated and very hopeful, it's almost $1.5 million that this school would have to borrow in order to function for a year.
This is a school with no track record, limited banking by a company that isn't even in California except for, I think, one other charter, no assets, no collateral,
And I don't see where they're ever going to get the line of credit.
I would say to you that if you want to have a technical correction to this, and that is they would have to show you where their line of credit is coming from before they can open this charter.
Also, to let you know that that piece of property they're talking about still shows as being for lease if you go on the website for the broker.
Thank you.
Okay.
If no more I will close the public hearing and now open it up for board discussion.
Member Rucker.
Okay, liaisons first.
Do you mind if I?
Okay.
I think what Cindy indicated to us early on is a very important point for us to remember.
This is not double jeopardy.
We're not trying somebody a second time.
We have already approved this charter, but we are now looking at this material revision, not the value of the charter, not that as a whole, but this change in terms of the delay in opening.
However, when we do that, it does change things about the petition.
It changes the budget.
It changes
A number of people that changes, you know, any number of things can be changed by a delay in opening material revision.
So those are things that we really should look at and be very careful about.
not the original discussion we had in May about this charter school, and if we can keep those things separate I think we will be doing what we're asked to do for this one, so I just wanted to say that again, remind people of that again, and leave it up to you of course now for other comments.
Do you Member Williams as the other liaison want to make a comment on this?
I would just add to that in terms of it wasn't a surprise to me either that they would need probably to have a material amendment related to facilities.
Whenever a charter petition denial process happens and takes a long time and they wind up to us in May,
then it's not uncommon for them not to have been able to secure a facility until they had for certain authorization and then it takes a while to make that happen.
This isn't the first one that we've had where we have, where this has been brought to us for the sole reason of facilities and needing to get the facility in place.
Thank you.
Member Rucker?
And Ting, did you have your hand up?
Okay.
Okay, so I agree.
Again, I'm always happy to serve in the company of some really smart people on this board because Board Member Holliday said part of what I wanted to speak to and he actually said it better than I did.
This is not a hearing to re-litigate the board's decision to approve this charter.
But it is a hearing to consider what is the sustained effect of extending the opening date on this charter because of the problems that they did have with securing a facility and then doing the work to open the facility.
So the board member, Holiday, did bring up some questions I did have concerning other parts of the charter petition itself.
that have an impact on this delayed opening.
And so I'm going to try to be very careful asking these questions because I do not want to relitigate the issues concerning the charter.
I am concerned that the budget may be different because there are some cost considerations that were not anticipated by the charter operators because they now have to wait this additional year.
you know, the cost for doing whatever the refab is or whatever it is they have to do to get the building ready and get their certificate and get their permit and do all the work that they have to do.
Their budget didn't include the work with an attorney to go through all of these things.
And is that going to have a material impact on what their revenue looks like?
So that wasn't considered or addressed or identified by the charter.
So I have a concern about that impact.
I have a concern because of where the neighborhood is, whether or not they will be able to meet
their anticipated student enrollment because of where the facility is and if that's going to change the type of students who end up being enrolled there.
And as a result, if they have a budget that anticipates a particular number of students who are part of that unduplicated population, is there really going to be this issue that the district identified?
But now that's not relitigating whether or not
They have a viable program or a viable budget.
I think that there are some things that probably have not been considered or contemplated that's going to have a different impact on this charter.
That said, I was confused.
I'm not surprised that they haven't signed a lease.
So yeah, I'm sure if we do go on the website and we look at that building, we will see that it's still being listed as for lease.
They probably haven't signed a lease yet because they can't obligate themselves
to a building that they haven't been approved to lease or you know to make that financial obligation if this is not going to be approved.
So that part doesn't bother me but I am concerned that even giving them the additional planning year
There may be some other unintended revenue issues that are not in front of us that are probably going to be of concern that are going to create another problem for them at some point down the road.
I am impressed that they have taken the time to look at what the timeline will be for working with the city
and for doing the work with their architects.
But there are some other cost pressures in that work that wasn't anticipated and I don't believe that have been considered.
So approving this may create more problems than it actually solves.
But that is a concern that wasn't addressed by either the district or it wasn't properly addressed or identified by the district.
The district has the, they had the,
presence of mind to identify that there are some issues with their budget and with their finances, but it's on the charter operators to figure those things out and to explain to us how those were addressed, how are they going to address them, and that they recognize those issues.
They didn't do that.
I don't know if they didn't do that because it is something they are not aware of, or they don't know right now what those issues will be, but I do think that there are going to be some concerns that are currently not anticipated.
Again, I am trying to very carefully raise those concerns because I do not want to relitigate
the quality or the efficacy of the charter application, I just, I think that we do need to be aware there are some other cost pressures that will, that right now are unanticipated by what this delay will actually mean.
And I'm hoping, I see Board Member Ting's son shaking her head yes, so I'm hoping I'm not missing the target on explaining what my concern is.
Cindy, could you come back up and address from the department perspective the comments about these financial issues?
Would you clarify?
We start with the budget that's submitted with the material revision and some of the issues that the district pointed out, what we do is we look at their budget and then we make our own adjustments to that.
So we look at their assumptions but then
Did they submit a different budget from the one that we saw in May?
I just want to clarify.
Because everything shifts.
This is a different budget.
All right.
Thank you.
And then our adjustments actually, I mean, they understated LCFF revenues, so that actually increased.
their revenues.
And then we removed some things.
We reduced lottery because of timing, some of the things the district said.
We increased expenditures because they may have provided assumptions, but we are a little more conservative sometimes in what we look at based on historical budgets we've looked at for state board schools, and so we've made those adjustments.
The facility is a little unknown because at the time there was really, there's no lease agreement, so it's really difficult to know what that would cost, but they have built lease costs within the budget, but it is year one, which means it begins in 2017-18, but they had made a statement that they anticipated
that the potential landlord would include all tenant improvement and related costs into the price of the lease.
So at that point, the first year lease costs look like it could be reasonable without any sort of agreement.
The first year costs, though, those are the ones we had, there were no assumptions for that.
So anything in the planning phase that hasn't been built in to the budget, there is some wiggle room for them, but I don't know what those costs would be.
Okay, Member Ortiz-Lacombe, and then Member Sang after that.
When I was reviewing this item, the charter wasn't ringing a bell, and that's because I think I missed all, like a day marathon of charters on May 12th.
I left that day.
Yeah, and so one of the things that I think is standard across all charter schools, it's so difficult to find a facility in most of these build-out communities, and this is going to be a recurring theme that we see.
You know, going through the process of working with the city and trying to get the conditional use permits, also a nightmare.
So I am very sympathetic to that.
When I was looking at the new languages that have been identified, and again, I don't have background because I wasn't here,
It does seem aggressive to teach four different languages within that grade span identified, to find teachers that are qualified to teach those four different languages.
I've had the privilege of traveling to different schools across the country that offer more than one language, and it is extremely difficult to find the teachers, to find the parents that are willing to enroll their kids in some of the
languages like German and French.
So that for me, I understand the district's concern because if something should happen to the charter, God willing, nothing will.
But if something should happen, then you do have students that may come back to the district with some language gaps.
However, again, I wasn't here during the initial hearing, so I wasn't previewed to the entire conversation.
And for that reason, I'm just going to sit back and just express that I understand the concerns around the facilities and I do wish you luck in finding your new site and making sure that you secure it.
And remember, we had a very lengthy hearing and testimony, and we debated those very issues and discussed them.
So just so you know, they did come out during the hearing as well.
And there were some clarifying steps and strategies that were shared by the petitioners at the time.
OK, Member Sun.
Thank you.
So I was nodding to Member Rucker's comments because absolutely with the delay that there would be some additional and unanticipated costs, et cetera.
However, on the other hand, I feel that by having this delay, it also provides the school more time to recruit.
I remember in that discussion that because of the wide variety of languages that
school wanted to provide in this dual immersion model that we were a little bit not sure if all of those languages would have had the classes and the numbers that they needed.
It could in some ways help balance out by having that additional time in that.
And I don't know if the petitioners want to address that or if the department has already looked at some of those factors, but I don't think that's necessarily all bad as far as impact eventually on the program.
going to go to public comment.
I think it's a good thing.
I think charter schools do need a lot of time to get ready before the door opens and the child walks in.
I have seen any number of charters who have tried to rush that process and it has not turned out to be in the best interest of the children.
So I'm really happy about delaying the opening of the starter school as a means for allowing the staff and the teachers and the parents and the kids and the building to get ready for next September or August and opening the door for the kids.
I think it's a good thing.
Okay so we're gonna go to public comment now and then we'll come back for any other board comments.
So this time we have any public comment on this request?
So your microphone's not on?
Okay, go ahead.
So do we have it specified one minute per comment?
Okay.
Mr. Aguilar, go ahead.
Jesse Aguilar with the California Teachers Association.
This charter is not very far along in the process.
We believe that more due diligence should have been exercised and the charter should have been further along in the process before asking for the specific date.
The process should not be used as a placeholder.
If a school is going to build parent expectations on when it will open, there should be a concerted effort to open on that date.
Therefore, CTA opposes the material revision and urges the state board to disapprove.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Dr. Armina Garperian, President of the Glenelg Unified School District Board of Education.
We are here today to ask you to deny Isla Charter School's request for material revision.
GUSC has a long history of supporting parent choice programs.
However, we do not believe that the Isla offers a quality program that will benefit our students.
Numerous material concerns led both GUSD and L.A.
County to deny ISLA's original charter petition.
The fact that ISLA is already requesting a material revision to their charter further proves that these concerns were valid.
GUSD operates one of the largest, strongest dual immersion programs in the state of California.
Our program has been recognized by LACO, CABE, and California's Together, and is being recognized this October by the L.A.
County Board of Supervisors.
We understand what it takes to operate a high-quality dual immersion program, and we are confident when we say that the program ISLA is proposing does not have the capacity to be successful.
ISLA has already had a delay opening their school for one year.
We do not believe that they have a plan that can be put into action without many more significant material changes.
Thank you.
My name is Jennifer Freeman.
I'm also a member of the Glendale Unified School District School Board and I am a parent of three children enrolled in Franklin's dual immersion program and actually now one at the middle school level at Roosevelt Middle School.
One of ISLA's contentions was that we are not offering K-12 pathways for dual immersion in the district.
We have currently three middle schools that are offering the program and one high school that is moving into the program, so this frankly is just not true.
The enrollment issue is not one we, again, we offer schools of choice.
We have been responsive to our community.
We are doing it well, and I think doing it better than, frankly, ESLA is going to be available to.
So I am asking that you deny the request for material revision.
I'm confident that there is not strong enough interest in our Glendale community.
We do not have a community that desires this charter and we want to really see it go away because it does not meet our community needs.
It is not something that we believe is going to work for children.
We're here in the best interest of our kids and we want to see them do well and not have to pick up the pieces from a failed charter.
Thank you.
This is my sixth year as principal of Franklin.
Could you introduce your name, please?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm Vicky Atikian.
This is my sixth year as principal of Franklin.
Prior to being principal, I was an administrator at the district office providing support for dual language programs.
I have firsthand knowledge of what it takes to create and maintain successful dual language programs.
It takes extensive knowledge and experience in language acquisition, hiring qualified teachers, development of curriculum and assessments, and effective professional development.
These lead job posting for the principal does not reference experience with dual immersion programs or methodologies.
It requires only one year of any administrative experience and none at the elementary level.
Also, the principal position does not start until May 2017.
This is too late for teacher recruitment and hiring, for student recruitment, and for the purchase of instructional materials.
The ESLIP petitioners do not seem to have the qualifications and understanding necessary to open and sustain an educationally sound dual immersion program across levels and languages, especially within this short timeline.
Thank you.
I'm Tali Narsanyan, the president of the Glendale Teachers Association, representing the phenomenal teachers of Glendale.
I'd like to yield my time to Donald Cohen, please.
Good afternoon.
I am Alicia Harris, teacher at Crescent Valley High School in Glendale Unified and the vice president of the Glendale Teachers Association.
I too yield my time to Donald Cohen.
That's me.
I'm Donald Kahn, the Executive Director of In the Public Interest.
We're a nonprofit research and policy group.
So I want to talk a little bit about, and I'm handing out a memo, about the process a little bit about this, because we have a little bit of a different view on material revisions and the issue there.
So we look back at the approvals, the applications that came to the State Board since 2002.
And I'm going to give you my conclusions, and I'm going to go through the numbers, and then hopefully I'll do that within a couple of minutes.
So first, we found that we believe the State Board is approving
a good number, maybe a too good a number, of local charter petitions that have been rejected by school districts in which they are going to operate.
That raises issues of local control and capacity.
Second, a significant number of the charter schools approved by the State Board have either been closed or not yet open.
I'll give you the numbers in a bit.
Third, the Board is considering a large number of material revisions that suggest potential issues that could and should have been addressed in the original proposal.
Fourth, we think this indicates the potential for the need for a review of staffing capacity, not that staff is doing a bad job, but staff's capacity and the adequacy of staff to
to evaluate, to monitor schools and evaluate and monitor on the ground.
So let me give you a few numbers.
So since 2002, the state board has approved 74% of all charter petitions that have been appealed to the board following the rejections.
That's first.
Second is of those 43 that the State Board has approved on appeal, 15 of those were subsequently closed or have not yet opened.
That's a substantial number.
Next, we found that 20 of the 43 schools that were approved have had come back for material revisions, some more than once.
And again, within those, two have had their charters revoked, three never opened, and two are pending and not yet opened.
So in general, we think the process of regular material revisions speaks to the rigor of the process from the get-go.
This creates distortions, it creates disruptions for the local community and for kids that you've heard about.
So in general, I think there are actions you can take to look at the process in more depth within state statute.
In specific, I think given the concern about occupancy and when the Korean market will leave occupancy, the question is whether this will be another material revision in the first of many.
Thank you.
Almost good afternoon.
I'm Kelly King assistant superintendent for educational services for Glendale Unified School District.
Over 3000 of our students are enrolled in one of Glendale's dual immersion programs TK through 12.
And we know well and research supports that it's critical for students to remain in that dual immersion program through sixth grade.
CABE two way CABE and those are the letters I presented with you have grave concerns about ISLA and the dual immersion program it's proposing.
The delay continues to fuel those concerns.
There's very little instruction in those early years in English as it depends on those five years before language skills transfer.
I've given you a letter from Dr. Catherine Lindholm Leary that also supports the concerns that if this fails and if continued material revisions continues to delay or it opens without being fully realized that there's detriment to the kids.
We're asking that you deny the East Slip request for material revision and ask them to submit a more reasonable and reasoned petition for approval at the local level.
Our kids deserve a high quality program.
Thank you.
Cheryl Plotkin, I just want to clean up on a couple of items from what we found out.
One is we've been told by the grocery store that they are not moving out until June, in which they're moving to a new facility.
And two, one of the things they relied on to come up with the number of students they were going to have was our waiting list.
Where our waiting list for Franklin is 21 students from Glendale and 153 from outside the district.
Our concern about this is not the Glendale students, but it is our concern for all students in general.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
We're very concerned about this process of requiring schools to come up for material revisions for a delay.
The start date of a school is not an item within the scope of a charter.
You guys have been requiring that.
It goes beyond the law.
And worse yet, it creates an enormous practical barrier.
Good commercial properties come on the market.
They're often snapped up within hours, if not days.
Requiring a school to go through a months-long process to get a material revision takes them out of the marketplace when they need to be in, and it's just crippling.
In our view, this requirement is an abusive helicopter authorizer practice.
You have plenty of other tools to deal with the practical issues of making sure the facility
is safe and sound, but you need to stop doing this, please.
I have no problem with approving this revision for today, but going forward, I would urge you to rethink this requirement.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Colin Miller with the California Charter Schools Association.
I want to note that I do agree with Eric on his comments that this really does go beyond a material vision of the charter itself.
We're not here to talk about the educational program.
We're not here talking about how the program or governance or operation of the school will be structured.
The budget and the facilities issues are in statute very separate from the charter itself.
And so this really doesn't constitute a material revision to that charter.
So we would encourage you to look at more administrative processes so that these things can happen on a more timely basis.
So the school isn't delayed, in this case, at least two months from actually even being able to move forward on this issue.
We do strongly support the school in this issue.
We do know, of course, that as time goes by, budgets and assumptions do change.
Budgets are dynamic documents, and they will always be changing, even in the best of circumstances.
We do believe the school has at least acknowledged many of these assumptions and many of the contingencies that may be necessary in this case, and they're very capable to move forward.
Thank you.
So that ends the public comments.
So do we have continued board comments?
Member Littleton was gone.
I'm not going to be specific about this charter since I wasn't here.
But in general, this is the second time that I hear there were being helicopter stay aboard of it.
Is that what would you respond to that, Judy?
I think the testimony itself is the best response.
We heard from the school.
We heard from the district.
We heard from Cindy about all of the changes that are resulting from this delay in opening the budget, employee contracts, recruitment.
I think from a parent's perspective who thought they would have a school to attend this year and now they don't, I think it's hard to say that that's not a material change.
And we've heard of the domino effect, employee contracts, all of the other things that are affected because of this.
I think the testimony itself sort of
proved why it was a material change.
Member Holiday.
So I'm really sorry that there's so much animosity toward the charter school in the local district.
I don't ever like to have a divisive situation.
I'm sorry that it is this way in this case.
I hope that it will improve over time.
I also believe that all of us on the board were a bit concerned in May about
The short amount of time ISIL had to pull everything together, I feel more comfortable now that they're taking more time to do this.
I trust the CDE and their evaluation of the financial situation.
I hope recruiting will come along well.
I hope that the ties to the community will be mended, and I hope the Korean market works out.
Lots of hope, and I understand that that's an issue, that's a concern.
but I would go ahead and move the CDE recommendation.
I'll second.
Okay.
Do you have any board member comments on the motion?
I should probably know this, but on the opening date, do we require that petitions to the state board is actually put in the petition itself?
Or is that a... Yes.
Cindy?
It's not in the petition itself?
Could you come forward, Cindy, so we can hear?
The opening date isn't added to the charter petition, but there's this separate attachment on the item that's in every item that comes before you.
The parent's sign has the date.
Oh, you mean originally?
Yeah, maybe.
I don't want to hold up the vote, but I think the comments around the material revision, a material revision should be a material revision of the charter itself.
So if we're not asking them to put the opening date in the charter, is it technically a material revision?
Isn't it no later than September 30th of 2017?
Isn't that what we're doing?
We're just moving it one year.
Member Williams?
I believe that what Member Sun is raising is the same thing that were raised by Eric and Colin.
Is it, who do not feel like the date that a charter school opens, if that changes, that requires coming back to the board for a material revision?
and that's what was being raised by them and I think that Member Sun is raising that as well in terms of if is it in the charter itself and that's why we're requiring it and it should it be in the charter or is it more of an administrative thing.
Right.
And again, I'm not going to hold up the vote on this, but it is something that I think technically looking at, I believe we need to know when the charter is going to open.
And that is definitely a part of the process.
Mine is more on the technical aspect of what is considered material revision of the charter, which is the process.
So it isn't in the petition, but remember, the material revisions by law are required to follow the same standards and criteria that I always state.
Those standards and criteria is everything you look at in an initial approval of a charter that includes the budget, includes every document that we have to look at.
So it kind of puts that back into that same sort of place that we would on an establishment.
So we treat it the same other than we don't look at signatures.
There's a couple things we don't look at because they're not applicable.
I'm happy to continue some conversations with liaisons on this.
Member Rucker.
It's not the issue before.
So when the board took action to approve this charter, the idea was that the school was going to open in this school year.
And so it's not going to be open this school year.
Now, I don't think that they would, okay, Cindy, I'm saying this on purpose to be illustrative.
So originally the charter intended to open on September 30th.
They were going to end up having to open on October 1st instead of September 30th.
I somehow don't think that truly meets the definition of a seriously material revision in their charter.
But this charter, when it was approved, was supposed to open this school year.
The fact that they are not going to be able to open this school year and will open in a successive school year is something that this board, as the authorizer, should know.
How is this board, as the authorizer, supposed to know that?
That's the first question.
And then the second question is what is the impact on the charter itself in making that kind of significant delay in opening?
So what Cindy has explained is because of that significant delay in opening, not a day or two or a week or two,
the department in exercising their due diligence has to review if there are other fiscal or program issues that will be impacted in what the charter submitted in changing this delay.
So that's not a helicopter process.
That really is exercising the due diligence of this board in choosing to approve this charter.
So that's the reason why when I began my initial comment, I said I do not want to re-litigate.
the issues that were raised about the charter itself, the staff made the point that there are very few substantive impacts by allowing this charter the one-year delay.
So relitigating some of those things, while it's important to all the stakeholders that came, and I agree with and I have concerns about all the comments they raised,
The comment I had was, I'm not sure that all of the issues, and there are some assumptions, as Cindy pointed out, that we currently don't know.
And because of those assumptions that we currently don't know, I feel uninformed.
But my feeling of being uninformed about those assumptions has nothing to do with my reservations that the district has raised or even my own personal concerns that were raised by other stakeholders who testified at the hearing when this was approved by the board.
It's solely looking at and understanding what is the substantive impact.
So I'm not sensitive to the criticism of being a helicopter board in this regard.
I mean, we're either a helicopter board or we're just so charter friendly we'll approve, you know, a charter school that gets convened on a popsicle stick.
It depends on which side of the charter concern you are.
We're either a very great charter-friendly board, or we're so antagonistic that we hyper-litigate everything.
So it just depends on which side of the continuum you are.
So I'm not sensitive to that.
I think that the staff has done a good job of trying to explain what assumptions they are aware of, what things they are not aware of.
And so based on what they have explained, then it's up to this board to decide, do you have enough information to decide it's worthwhile to approve this extension, given the fact that the staff has already told you there are some things they don't know?
Thank you, Member Rucker.
Member Holiday?
This continues to happen with all of the charter school issues that come before this board, whether it's funding determination or whether it's appeals or whether it's renewals.
The fact is that in each of these cases, we get sidetracked with a larger discussion about
definitions and about process and all the rest.
So I would certainly welcome the opportunity to talk with staff and others about this issue about material revision moving forward.
But on the table today, right now, it's
this question and so once again I move the CDE recommendation and I and we've got a second.
So okay all those in support the CDE recommendation let's take a vote.
Six.
I'm not voting.
Motion passes.
No wait.
You abstain and.
I'm abstaining also.
Two abstentions.
So we have six yes and two abstention.
So the motion passes.
OK.
Thank you.
So that ends our public hearings.
And now we're open to general public comments.
Do we have any?
Lorraine Richards, Jesse Aguilar, and Angela DeRosa.
Would those that have signed up for public comment please come forward.
Good afternoon.
The individual that I'm introducing, I'm waiting to come in from the other overflow room, but my name is Lorraine Richards, California Teacher Association.
I have the pleasure of introducing a colleague that is going to be in addition to the CTA liaison for the teachers in that.
You've seen her come up and that's
Hi, I'm Angela de Ramos.
I just want to thank you for giving me this opportunity.
I've been a 21-year veteran of the classroom, and I just see this as one more trajectory in being an advocate for children.
Thank you.
Welcome.
Jessie, you were signed up for public comment?
Any more public comments?
That closes the public comment and I believe I can now close the board state board meeting for September.
Thank you very much.